Salut, ici Guillaume Hachez. Vous écoutez Septante Minutes Avec. Salut tout le monde, c'est déjà le dernier épisode de 2021 et pour terminer en beauté, je vous propose un épisode très spécial.
Comme je l'ai annoncé il y a quelques semaines, je reçois aujourd'hui Myriam Leroy pour la deuxième fois. Vous aviez pu entendre notre rencontre il y a trois ans dans Septante Minutes Avec
et, depuis, elle a été un grand soutien pour moi et une fidèle auditrice.
Elle m'a suggéré plein d'invités, elle m'a aidé à les contacter, tout ça, tout ça. Donc c'est mon bon plan pour cette année 2022.
Si vous voulez lancer un podcast, devenez vite pote avec Myriam. Pour celles et ceux qui ne sont pas au courant, Myriam a coréalisé avec Florence Hainaut le documentaire Sale Pute,
qui parle de cyberharcèlement et, toujours sur cette même thématique, elle a aussi écrit le roman Les Yeux rouges.
Et la raison pour laquelle elle a été centrée sur le harcèlement, ces dernières années, vous l'avez peut-être lu dans la presse, c'est précisément parce qu'elle a connu un harcèlement très violent.
Et après quatre années de procédure, on a appris ce mardi que le harceleur de Myriam était jugé coupable. Ça a été une grande victoire pour elle et c'est rare d'arriver à ce résultat-là.
On a une législation en Belgique où les insultes et les calomnies misogynes ou homophobes sur les réseaux sociaux correspondent à ce qu'on appelle un délit de presse.
Donc c'est une très vieille législation du 19e siècle et il a vraiment fallu qu'elle se batte pour que son harcèlement soit reconnu comme tel. Du coup,
dans cet épisode, on revient en exclusivité sur les faits qu'elle a subis, sur la façon dont elle l'a vécu,
sur la couverture de l'affaire dans la presse et on tente de prendre un peu de hauteur et de fournir une analyse des systèmes qui entrent en jeu.
C'est assez clair que j'ai absolument pas de distance par rapport au sujet. Ce que vous allez entendre, c'est avant tout deux amis qui discutent.
C'est un témoignage d'une femme qui a subi un harcèlement et qui s'est battue dans les tribunaux pour obtenir gain de cause.
On n'est pas dans une situation où je vais confronter plusieurs témoignages. C'est d'ailleurs le but assumé de cet épisode, donner la parole à Myriam, puisqu'elle est restée silencieuse dans les médias pendant toute cette affaire.
Et en gros, si vous essayez aujourd'hui de trouver les détails, vous allez surtout tomber sur la version du condamné.
C'est maintenant enfin l'heure pour Myriam de prendre la parole. Let's go ! On a combien de temps devant nous en fait ?
Moi, j'ai tout le temps, ouais.
OK, nickel. Qu'est-ce que t'as en tête pour cet entretien exactement ?
Tu enregistres déjà là ?
Bah oui.
OK, pardon. Bah en fait, j'avais envie depuis longtemps déjà de simplement m'exprimer sur le procès que je viens de gagner.
Enfin, j'avais envie de m'exprimer sur cette affaire parce que je l'ai jamais fait. Alors certes,
j'ai écrit un roman et je l'ai adapté au théâtre, d'une histoire inspirée de la mienne, mais c'est pas mon histoire, ça reste de la fiction.
J'ai jamais eu l'occasion de parler. Et donc ce qui fait que le narratif des harceleurs, et je mets harceleurs au pluriel, est devenu la version officielle, j'ai l'impression.
La version par défaut. Quand on fait une recherche sur ton nom-
Ouais
...on voit des gens qui parlent de toi, soit de façon-
Oui
...relativement agressive, soit, voilà, sans tenir compte de tes expériences et de ton vécu, puisque tu les as jamais vraiment partagées.
Voilà, exactement. Et y a des informations absolument délirantes qui, à force d'être martelées, semblent devenir la vérité et c'est très dérangeant.
C'est même ce qui se retrouve dans beaucoup de récits de presse. Et j'ai jamais eu l'occasion de rectifier. On m'a jamais demandé non plus.
Ben voilà. Donc, comme je t'avais sous la main, je m'étais dit que peut-être ce serait bien qu'on fasse ça ensemble.
Alors, pour plus de transparence, on a déjà enregistré une première version. C'était avant le verdict, avant le prononcé du jugement.
Et en fait, j'étais pas très contente de cette interview et donc je t'ai menacé pour que tu ne la sortes pas et que tu publies celle-là à la place.
Non, j'étais pas très contente parce que je trouvais que ça manquait un peu de hauteur, que c'était un peu-
Mh, on était un peu trop dans les tranchées, ouais.
C'était un peu-
On était un peu trop-
Ouais, et ça pouvait avoir l'air bac à sable. Et c'est quelque chose qui m'est souvent reproché. 'Fin voilà, on me dit souvent que ce sont des affaires de bac à sable, alors que non, pas du tout.
Et ça fait des années que je me bats pour essayer de montrer que ce qui se joue là-dedans, ce sont des violences systémiques, que c'est un problème collectif qui nous regarde tous.
Et là, j'avais l'impression d'un peu sortir-- 'fin voilà, d'être un peu trop, mh-
Y a effectivement un commentaire politique à faire, un commentaire d'un point de vue sociétal, systémique, comme tu dis.
Et effectivement, on était plus dans, voilà, quelque chose de très conversationnel. On se faisait des vannes, on était chill.
Mh.
Donc y a beaucoup de choses qui ressortaient, des émotions, un agacement. Oui, beaucoup d'émotions dans ta voix.
Ouais.
Oui, et on va essayer de se rapprocher de ce qu'on fait d'habitude
dans Septante Minutes Avec, c'est-à-dire d'abord reposer le contexte, bien expliquer ce qui s'est passé et puis essayer de, oui, de prendre de la hauteur et analyser un peu tout ça.
Maintenant, t'as pas de chance parce que j'ai une gueule de bois absolument démentielle parce que j'ai beaucoup fêté-
Mh, j'étais là aussi
...ce verdict de procès. Donc voilà, aujourd'hui, c'est une journée sans cerveau. Là, j'ai l'impression d'avoir perdu un peu d'espérance de vie et quelques neurones dans la bataille, mais je suis d'excellente humeur, évidemment.
Et oui, et on peut préciser aussi, de nouveau pour la transparence, que j'étais au procès.
Ouais.
Donc y a eu deux séances, une en septembre et une en octobre.
Oui, et donc j'étais présent. Ça me permettra de faire des commentaires sur ce qu'on a pu observer et entendre, voilà, dans le tribunal au Palais de Justice de Bruxelles.
Reposons bien le contexte avant de se lancer là-dedans. Ce harceleur, qui est-il ? Qu'est-ce qu'il t'a fait ?
Alors, je vais pas donner son nom parce que je crois qu'il serait trop content.
Mh.
Je pense qu'il porte vraiment ces accusations et cette condamnation comme une médaille hein, qu'il est content, voilà, ça lui fait quelque chose à vivre, je pense.
Donc c'est un homme qui doit avoir 45 ans, quelque chose comme ça, qui s'est invité sur mon lieu de travail quand je travaillais à La Libre Belgique en 2010.
Il m'a été présenté par une copine commune, je pense. Je lui ai serré la main. Voilà, un type-- il voulait me rencontrer, je savais pas trop pourquoi et j'ai dit bonjour.
'Fin, j'avais pas de raison de me dérober à ces présentations. Puis il m'a fait une demande d'amitié Facebook que j'ai acceptée
parce qu'à l'époque, j'avais comme seul précepte et principe par rapport à Facebook d'accepter les gens que je connaissais dans la vraie vie.
Et donc vu que je lui avais serré la main, j'estimais qu'il faisait partie de la vraie vie. Et puis voilà. Et le mec était assez affable au début.
Il m'envoyait des messages plutôt gentils, en mode admiratif. Il m'écoutait à la radio, lisait ce que j'écrivais. J'étais genre chroniqueuse, je pense à l'époque, pour La Libre, pour Focus Vif et pour Pure FM, je crois.
Et puis alors, je le signale parce que lui, il le signale tout le temps, mais pour moi, ça n'a aucune espèce d'importance à une époque.
Donc moi, j'étais jeune journaliste, je galérais quand même pas mal dans ce milieu, dans ce métier. Et
Safia Kessas, qui était la productrice de l'émission « Tout ça nous rendra pas le Congo » m'avait remarquée et m'avait proposé de proposer des sujets pour son émission.
J'étais évidemment hyper contente. C'était une super opportunité professionnelle pour moi. Et donc j'avais suggéré à Safia de faire un sujet sur JD, on va l'appeler JD.
Mmm. Et pourquoi JD ?
Parce qu'il était blogueur. Il était blogueur, il parlait beaucoup de musique, il se prenait un peu pour Alain Pacadis, très poseur.
Et c'était une personnalité excentrique. Et je me disais-- et voilà, en Belgique, les blogs, ça avait pas encore explosé.
L'expression de soi non plus, ça restait quand même assez spécial. Et je me disais qu'il y avait quelque chose à filmer là-dedans. Je lui ai proposé-
Qu'est-ce que tu veux dire quand tu dis qu'il est excentrique ?
Bah c'est un type-- alors, je veux pas en dire trop parce que ça permettrait trop de l'identifier, je crois, parce qu'il a une excentricité assez singulière.
Mais disons que c'était un type qui se prenait pour un rocker, pour un bad boy alors qu'il travaille dans une banque. Voilà, en gros.
OK, oui. Donc c'est-
Y a des gens très bien qui travaillent dans une banque et y a certainement des gens qui ont l'esprit rock 'n' roll qui travaillent dans une banque, mais y avait comme une tension, un décalage en fait dans ce qu'il montrait de lui-
OK, donc-- d'accord. Donc c'est ça qui t'a intéressée, c'est ce décalage finalement entre l'image qu'il envoyait sur Internet et comment il était en face à face.
Oui, et puis à l'époque, rien qu'avoir un blog, c'était particulier.
Tout le monde n'avait pas un blog, alors que bon maintenant, tout le monde est plus ou moins son propre blogueur et qu'on peut estimer que via Facebook, c'est un peu ça la monstration de soi qui est faite.
Mais le personal branding à temps plein, c'était pas vraiment quelque chose qui était très répandu.
Donc il était pour moi singulier.
Oui, donc tu es amie avec lui sur Facebook, tu te dis : « Il est singulier, un peu spécial. Y a peut-être un sujet à faire ».
Ouais.
Tu lui envoies une proposition.
Ouais. D'abord, il me dit oui, puis il me dit qu'il doit réfléchir, puis il me dit : « Bah non, j'en ai discuté avec ma femme, on va certainement passer pour des cons.
Donc voilà, je préfère te dire non ». Et moi, en fait, dans l'intervalle, parce qu'il a mis un certain temps avant de me répondre, j'étais assez soulagée qu'il me dise non.
Parce que je le voyais de plus en plus agressif sur les réseaux sociaux, de plus en plus raciste, de plus en plus sexiste et ça me mettait extrêmement mal à l'aise et je me disais : « Merde,
tout ça pour essayer de saisir une opportunité professionnelle qui m'était offerte ».
J'allais devoir me retrouver enfermée dans la même pièce que ce type pendant des heures, des heures, le temps d'un tournage et ça m'inquiétait en fait.
Donc j'étais contente qu'il me dise non et soulagée. Et puis nos conversations, enfin, je peux pas dire que ce sont des conversations.
'Fin, de temps en temps, il me sollicitait, il me parlait, je répondais : « Aha, lol ». Voilà, par politesse uniquement.
Et se sont poursuivies pendant quelque temps. Et puis il s'est mis à insulter mon compagnon de l'époque, sur les réseaux, de manière absolument cruelle, absurde, ordurière et déloyale, me semble-t-il.
Et je lui ai demandé d'arrêter. Et il m'a dit : « Non, mais tu sais bien, j'ai un personnage comme ça. Moi, je provoque, mais au fond de moi, je suis un agneau ».
Mmh.
Je dis : « Oui, mais bon, OK. Alors si t'arrêtes pas, moi, en fait, je vais pas pouvoir te garder dans mes amis Facebook.
Tu comprends bien que je peux pas assister comme ça ».
Tu lui as dit ça formellement ?
Ouais. Et-
Et pour qu'on ait un peu une idée, ce genre d'insultes, à quel point est-ce que c'était violent ? De quoi est-ce qu'on parle exactement ?
Non, alors c'était plus que des insultes, c'était des insinuations qui pouvaient même être préjudiciables à Dan, qui-- c'était le nom de mon ex-compagnon-
Uh uh
...comme quoi il aurait bâti sa carrière à force de pistons, qu'il vendait aucun ticket de spectacle parce qu'il est humoriste.
Uh uh. Dan Gagnon, pour ceux dans ce podcast.
Oui, c'est ça. En fait, il en brossait un portrait d'humoriste subventionné qui-- y avait quelque chose, un sous-entendu comme quoi il escroquait en fait quasi le contribuable quoi.
C'est-- bon, c'est un discours qui revient souvent, l'artiste subventionné payé avec nos impôts parce que t'as une pauvre chronique à 75 balles à la RTBF.
Alors que bon, s'il y a bien quelqu'un qui s'est fait absolument tout seul et qui n'a été aidé par personne, c'est Dan.
Et donc je pouvais pas, voilà, j'avais pas envie de lire ça. J'avais pas envie d'avoir dans mes amis Facebook simplement quelqu'un qui dise de la merde comme ça sur mon mec.
Et donc je lui ai dit que j'allais le retirer de mes amis, ce que j'ai fait. Et puis c'est là qu'il s'est retourné
et qu'il a commencé à mordre et que je suis devenue, 'fin voilà, c'était Dan sa tête de Turc et puis c'est devenu moi.
Et à partir d'octobre 2012, il n'a cessé de m'agonir d'injures à caractère sexiste et sexuel,
à retweeter, partager absolument toutes les autres insultes d'autres internautes à mon sujet, partager des photomontages pornographiques qui me mettaient en scène,
faire des intrusions diverses, sur mon téléphone par exemple, me bousculer dans l'espace public, et puis me faire un geste obscène, essayer par tous les moyens de s'abonner à des réseaux que j'avais pourtant privés et sécurisés.
Donc je le voyais surgir comme ça de temps en temps dans mes abonnements, les tentatives d'abonnement à mon compte Instagram.
Voilà, et ça dure et je le conjugue au présent depuis donc le 18 octobre 2012.
Mmm-hmm. On parle de-- tu disais photomontages pornographiques, donc on parle de, voilà, donc du sang, du sperme, des ecchymoses-
Oui
...sur ta face. Et donc il t'a rencontrée, il t'a bousculée et-
Alors il m'a téléphoné, il m'a envoyé-
Oui
...un message WhatsApp. Voilà, en tout cas-
Il t'a aussi suggéré, je crois, une opération de chirurgie esthétique.
Ah oui, mais ça, ça fait partie des nombreuses choses qu'il m'a suggérées.
Oui, oui, bah alors y a de tout hein, c'était des insultes sur mon physique, des insultes aussi, des insinuations sur,
hmmm, ma soi-disant absence de déontologie professionnelle, que je coucherais pour obtenir des collaborations avec la presse.
Quand j'obtiens des autorisations de tournage, c'est parce que je les ai eues avec mon cul, évidemment.
Voilà, donc mais essentiellement, moi, ce qui me mettait hors de moi, c'était toutes les insinuations et les insultes à caractère sexuel et sexiste qui me réduisaient à mes orifices quoi.
Mmm-hmm.
Et mais pendant des années, on m'a dit
: « Allez, tu dois t'en foutre, c'est un con, c'est personne, ça doit pas te faire souffrir, ne lui accorde pas d'attention, tu lui ferais de la pub si tu parlais de lui.
» Et donc bah j'ai écouté ce qu'on me disait et j'ai fermé ma gueule pendant des années jusqu'à un moment où en fait ça a été la goutte de trop.
Et là, je me suis dit : « Non, mais ça suffit en fait, on va arrêter, ça suffit. »
Et qu'est-ce qui a été la goutte de trop ?
Alors y a eu un message, en 2016 où il disait sous la publication de quelqu'un qui était invité dans mon émission, parce que j'avais une émission à la RTBF à l'époque qui s'appelle « Coupez !
Au montage ! » Et quelqu'un, un artiste disait qu'il allait venir être interviewé par moi. Et JD a répondu,
que j'étais une inculte doublée d'une peste avec les oreilles décollées qui connaissait le goût du zizi de Dan Gagnon.
Et puis que maintenant, en fait, je sortais avec machin et que machin habitait-- enfin voilà. Et là, je me suis dit : « Non, mais ça, OK, là, je vais faire des captures d'écran parce qu'à mon avis, un jour, ça va me servir.
» Et oui, parce qu'on m'encourageait pas à faire des captures d'écran. S'il y avait un truc de bonne pratique, parce qu'on me demande toujours quelles sont les bonnes pratiques pour éviter d'être harcelé via les réseaux sociaux.
Et moi, je refuse en général de répondre à ça parce que je trouve que les bonnes pratiques, c'est pas sur les harcelés, c'est pas sur les victimes en fait qu'il faut les,
qu'il faut les communiquer, c'est sur les harceleurs ou aux spectateurs quoi, qu'il faut les adresser.
Mais s'il y a peut-être une bonne pratique une fois qu'on est harcelé, c'est de faire des captures, et en faire le plus possible et d'avoir la possibilité, la datation de la capture, la date, l'heure de l'infraction.
Et ça fait des pièces à conviction après pour l'éventuel procès.
Ouais, c'est ça.
S'il y en a un.
Et pas faire comme moi, désactiver ses comptes Facebook et Twitter sans avoir fait assez de captures, supprimer les comptes pour avoir la paix sans avoir assuré ses arrières.
Parce que voilà, mon dossier, finalement, devant la justice, il était assez pauvre. Enfin, y avait que 40 pièces dedans, alors que c'est un harcèlement qui a duré deux mille ans quoi.
Et puis j'ai eu un message d'insulte anonyme via un formulaire de contact d'un site et via le forum de La Première, parce que c'était à l'époque, La Première avait un forum, c'était horrible ce forum, putain, c'était vraiment la poubelle.
Et donc j'y ai reconnu en fait la patte de JD, puisque JD—
Parce qu'il parlait de tes oreilles.
...était obsédé par mes oreilles. Elles sont trop mignonnes, mes oreilles. Certes, ce sont un peu des oreilles de lutin, mais moi, je les aime bien.
Mais donc voilà, et personne d'autre au monde ne m'a jamais fait chier sur mes oreilles que lui.
Non, c'est fou hein.
Ouais. Même à l'école, même dans la cour de récré, on me faisait pas chier là-dessus. On me faisait chier sur autre chose, mais pas là-dessus. Et donc
voilà, j'ai envoyé une lettre recommandée de plainte au procureur du roi en disant voilà : « Je dépose plainte, c'est ce message anonyme-là qui m'a fait sortir de mes gonds, donc je le joins à une plainte pour l'ensemble de l'œuvre de JD.
» Il se fait que ça a été classé sans suite,
une fois, deux fois. Et puis que j'ai décidé, puisque je savais que j'allais avoir le soutien de l'Association des journalistes professionnels qui avait payé mes frais de justice et sans eux, je n'aurais rien pu faire.
J'ai décidé de me constituer partie civile avec une avocate et donc de douiller 250 balles pour qu'un juge soit obligé de se pencher sur ma requête et ne la classe pas sans suite directement.
Voilà, et c'est comme ça. C'est à partir de là, c'est-à-dire en octobre 2017, que j'ai déposé plainte avec constitution de partie civile.
Et octobre 2017, ça coïncide aussi avec le dévoilement de MeToo en fait. Et je pense que ce n'est pas totalement étranger au fait que cette fois, la justice a estimé que c'était un sujet peut-être important et que non—
Ok, donc c'est intéressant.
...contrairement au classement sans suite qui m'avait été signifié, les conséquences de poursuites au pénal ne seraient pas disproportionnées par rapport aux faits commis.
Parce que moi, les courriers que je recevais, c'est ça qu'ils me disaient, les—
Oui, oui, oui. C'est intéressant parce que je m'attendais à ce que tu dises c'est en raison du contexte MeToo que peut-être ça t'a encouragée à lancer ces démarches, mais tu dis même pas, non, c'était indépendant de ça.
Ouais.
Tu l'aurais fait—
Bah oui, je l'ai fait avant puisque c'est en février 2017 que j'ai déposé ma première plainte. Et quand on dépose plainte, en général, enfin non, je parle pour moi, mais c'est vraiment que
tu as épuisé toutes les autres possibilités de t'en sortir, tous les autres recours et il n'y a aucun retour en arrière possible.
Enfin moi, en tout cas, pour moi, y a pas de retour en arrière possible. Jamais, pour rien.
Donc tu as déposé plainte en octobre 2017. Ça a pris longtemps. Ça a pris quatre ans pour arriver à un résultat, un jugement.
Ouais.
Beaucoup de délais, tu disais, des coûts importants.
Comment est-ce que tu as pu gérer, voilà, l'aspect financier de la question ?
Ah ben uniquement parce que l'AJP a une assurance protection juridique et que j'ai pu en bénéficier en tant que journaliste professionnelle détentrice de la carte de presse.
Voilà, et puis qu'ils ont estimé que ça les regardait aussi, que c'était en tant que femme journaliste, puisqu'en fait, ce type s'est insinué dans ma vie dans le cadre de mon métier.
C'est parce qu'il m'entendait à la radio et qu'il lisait ce que j'écrivais que ce type s'est invité dans mon existence.
C'est pas parce qu'il m'avait croisée au marché quoi.
Et donc ça, c'était évidemment une très très bonne nouvelle. Par contre, mes employeurs, 'fin mes clients, parce que bon, j'suis journaliste indépendante, mais à l'époque, j'étais plutôt fausse indépendante pour
diverses structures, c'est-à-dire que j'avais,
je cumulais quasi plusieurs temps pleins.
'Fin voilà, c'était vraiment la galère. Ils se sont pas constitués partie civile à mes côtés. C'était le cas aussi pour Julie Enno hein, qui est d'ailleurs la cousine de Florence.
J'sais pas si tu connais cette histoire, qui est une journaliste française qui a subi un raid absolument immonde
de menaces de mort, de menaces de viol de la part de néonazis en fait, suite à un article qu'elle a fait sur un café colonial à Lyon, j'pense.
Et elle critiquait en fait l'iconographie et la communication sur les bienfaits des colonies que le café mettait en avant dans son article. Et voilà—
Elle s'est tapé un facho store, ouais.
...ouais, ouais, mais d'une violence, mais inouïe. Et elle, elle a pas eu de chance parce qu'elle a été globalement déboutée. 'Fin
voilà, elle a pas obtenu gain de cause en justice.
Et je pense que c'est Reporters sans frontières et différentes associations qui se sont constituées partie civile à ses côtés, mais le journal pour lequel elle avait écrit cette chronique ne l'a pas fait.
Ouais, les institutions, de manière générale, ne sont pas—
Sont défaillantes, on peut le dire.
...à côté des femmes dans ces cas-là.
Oui.
Ouais, ouais, je t'en prie, je te laisse la maternité de tes propos.
Voilà, mais donc ça montre bien encore à quel point—
'fin moi, j'étais, parce que maintenant, j'apparais plus trop dans les médias, mais harcelée dans le cadre de chroniques qu'on me demandait de faire, dans le cadre d'une ligne éditoriale à laquelle je me conformais,
sur base de, j'vais pas dire d'ordres qu'on me donnait parce que ce serait pas vrai, mais d'indications quoi.
Et les médias n'ont jamais estimé qu'en fait, c'est peut-être qu'ils avaient, si pas une responsabilité dans ce qui m'arrivait, en tout cas une responsabilité de m'accompagner dans les suites. Ça, jamais.
Alors, on va revenir là-dessus un peu plus tard, si tu le veux bien. Simplement, j'aimerais parler de—
Du jugement ?
Oui, tout à fait.
Du procès.
Allons-y, allons-y. Donc le verdict, rappelle-nous, c'était donc cinq mois de prison avec sursis, c'est ça ?
Non, c'est 10 mois, avec sursis.
Oh, encore mieux.
Sursis probatoire, j'sais pas très bien ce que ça veut dire. Il doit aussi faire une formation de sensibilisation aux violences envers les femmes de 50 heures, payer une amende de 3 000 € et payer les dépens.
Ça, j'crois que c'est les frais de justice. J'sais pas très bien ce que c'est les dépens en fait. Voilà. Donc—
Sursis probatoire, ça veut dire que le—
T'as googlé. J'ai vu que tu venais de googler.
...mais j'aurais dû couper la cam. Mais ça veut dire que le but, c'est que lui prouve quelque chose quoi, prouve qu'il est en mesure de rester calme pendant ces cinq ans.
C'est ça.
Et donc effectivement, s'il est à nouveau condamné, il devra passer 10 mois en prison en plus—
Ouais, donc ça veut dire que pendant cinq ans, on m'a expliqué hier qu'il devait se tenir à carreau avec moi, mais aussi avec les autres.
Ouais, ouais, tout à fait.
Qui est quand même une très bonne nouvelle. Moi, je suis vraiment satisfaite de ce verdict, même si plein de gens me disent : « Quoi ?
10 mois de prison avec sursis, c'est juste une petite tape sur les doigts. En regard de presque 10 ans de harcèlement ».
C'est vrai. Et 3 000 €, c'est que dalle. Même 200 000 €, ce serait que dalle. J'veux dire y a pas de prix pour le fait que ce mec m'a dicté son agenda et son agenda dégueulasse pendant autant d'années.
Rien, aucune somme ne permettrait de laver tout ça en fait,
tout c'qui m'a fait subir. Parce que y a évidemment pas que son harcèlement à lui, y a toute cette campagne de dénigrement, de diffamation, de calomnie qu'il a organisée, tous les complices qu'il s'est trouvés et la manière absolument
immonde dont ils m'ont traînée dans la boue au vu et au su de tout le monde.
Ça, pour moi, y a rien, absolument rien qui pourrait le rembourser. Mais j'suis quand même très contente de cette décision parce que déjà, elle entérine le fait que oui, c'est délictuel, il pouvait pas faire ça.
C'est du harcèlement et c'est pas de l'humour, c'est pas de la liberté d'expression.
Est-ce que tu penses que ça fera un précédent pour les femmes en Belgique à l'avenir qui auront un vécu similaire au tien ?
Est-ce que ça sera un précédent ?
Oui, bien sûr, c'est une jurisprudence hein, c'est la première fois, mais il va très certainement aller en appel.
Et s'il perd l'appel, ce qui est probable, il ira très certainement en cassation parce que c'est un militant, il ira jusqu'au bout de sa démarche—
Il l'a annoncé sur Twitter d'ailleurs, ouais.
...ah, il l'a déjà annoncé sur Twitter ?
Non, non, pas encore, mais j'veux dire, avant que le jugement soit rendu, sur Twitter, il annonçait qu'inévitablement, il allait faire appel—
Oui, il a dit beaucoup de conneries hein, il avait dit aussi qu'il irait en cassation pour la décision de le renvoyer devant le tribunal correctionnel.
Voilà, faut pas trop y croire, faut pas croire tout ce qu'il dit, en tout cas. Mais voilà, oui, je pense qu'un appel, c'est assez probable.
Quoiqu'en appel, la peine pourrait être alourdie. Et je trouve que la peine est déjà assez exemplaire par rapport aux autres affaires de harcèlement que j'ai suivies, notamment en France, celles qui concernent Nadia Daam, par exemple.
Les peines étaient souvent plus légères quoi, que ça.
Effectivement, ouais, ouais. Si je me souviens bien, c'était des forumers de Jeuxvideo.com qui avaient fait en masse des commentaires désobligeants, misogynes, sexistes.
Nadia Daam, c'était ponctuel.
Oui, oui, c'était pas sur le long terme, ouais.
Moi, c'est un mec, ça fait très, oui, ça fait très longtemps qu'il s'acharne. Et ça, la juge l'a souligné aussi, 'fin qu'il n'avait pas l'air de prendre la mesure du tout de son comportement.
Et c'est, je pense que c'est ça aussi qui a aggravé, qui a alourdi la peine, sa peine, c'est son attitude aux audiences.
Alors, on va revenir sur la façon dont, comme tu disais, tu as été traînée dans la boue, sur la façon dont ça a été commenté dans la sphère publique.
Mais avant ça, j'aimerais parler du moment où le jugement et la sanction ont été donnés, comment est-ce que tu as réagi émotionnellement, intérieurement ?
Comment est-ce que tu as vécu ça ?
Bah, en fait, c'était vachement dur parce que ça a duré 40 minutes le prononcé du jugement et qu'avant ça, elle a pris d'autres affaires, la juge.
Donc en fait, c'était interminable et c'était très stressant. Et c'était— j'étais dans une tension absolue.
Surtout qu'elle m'a demandé de m'asseoir à l'avant. Donc moi, j'étais venue avec mon mec et quelques amis.
Puis j'avais mon avocate aussi. 'Fin, voilà, mais j'étais encore une fois tout devant, à découvert, très—
Lui, il n'était pas présent—
Lui, il n'était pas présent.
...contrairement aux audiences précédentes.
Oui, c'est ça. Et pendant au moins 20 minutes de sa lecture, on ne sait pas. C'est toujours pas— elle lit,
elle lit les éléments qui sont en faveur de l'accusé, puis les éléments qui sont en faveur d'une éventuelle condamnation.
Donc, tu dois faire des pronostics pendant 20, 25, 30 minutes même, avant d'entendre le mot, la sanction, avant d'entendre le mot « sanction ».
Mmh.
Et là, y a tout qui s'est relâché. J'ai poussé des petits cris de souris à la queue coincée dans une porte, dans le tribunal parce que je pleurais comme une merde. Je chialais.
C'est légitime, je pense hein.
Oui, oui. Mais moi, je pleure pas beaucoup, pas parce que j'suis forte et tout ça, mais parce que mes émotions prennent pas ce chemin-là en fait.
Ouais, ouais, moi non plus. Je comprends très bien.
Elles prennent plutôt le chemin des crises d'angoisse. Mais là, bah là, en fait, je pleurais, mais je pleurais de tension, de soulagement, de tension, de— 'fin, j'étais secouée de pleurs, en fait.
C'était horrible. Je m'étouffais dans mon masque en pleurant. Mais c'était un beau moment. D'ailleurs, rien que t'en parler, genre, de nouveau envie de pleurer.
Mais c'était un beau moment. C'était vraiment un—
Mais oui.
...'fin, c'était tellement fort et c'était tellement étonnant. J'étais très étonnée. Genre, jamais j'aurais pensé qu'elle prononcerait une peine de prison, même avec sursis.
Jamais, je pensais qu'il aurait—
Oui, on imaginait plutôt une peine de travail. Éventuellement, on imaginait ramasser plutôt les ordures sur le bord de l'autoroute.
Oui, c'est ça. Et on était déjà contents.
Voilà.
À l'idée de le voir faire quelque chose qu'il doit certainement trouver indigne de son grand talent.
De rocker.
Ouais.
Donc revenons alors maintenant sur avant cette libération.
Oui.
Ces dures années que tu as dû vivre, avec tous ces commentaires—
Ouais.
...sur les réseaux sociaux et éventuellement dans la presse. La façon dont ça a été couvert dans la presse, justement, y avait principalement un article du Vif qui avait tourné.
Mmh. Bah moi, j'ai jamais voulu participer à aucun article. Donc j'ai jamais répondu au téléphone aux journalistes qui, de temps en temps, c'était rare, mais
trouvaient que c'était pas mal d'avoir un contradictoire et de me donner la parole.
J'ai toujours demandé, à chaque fois que je savais qu'un papier allait être écrit, j'ai toujours demandé aux journalistes de pas publier ces papiers parce qu'en fait, à chaque fois qu'il y avait un article dessus,
ça remettait une pièce dans la machine du harcèlement.
Et c'était à chaque fois un moment très très pénible pour moi. Voilà, et puis c'était s'exprimer sur une affaire aussi qui était en cours, avec une instruction qui était ouverte.
Et donc ça se fait pas. On ne commente pas les affaires en cours, je crois. 'Fin, c'est ce qu'on m'a toujours dit. Mais il se fait que, selon toute vraisemblance, l'accusé a organisé une fuite judiciaire, alors en 2018, je pense.
Et ouais, c'est ça, en 2018. Et qu'en avril 2018, y a Sud Presse qui a publié un premier papier qui donnait libre cours à la version de l'accusé, qui est toujours la même.
Enfin non, 'fin, cette version, c'est : « Je suis le pauvre petit harcelé, je suis un père de famille sans histoire qui rase les murs.
Je n'ai fait que de l'humour. » C'était de la critique, de la satire citoyenne, en fait, hein, quatrième pouvoir, évidemment, comme ça, qui se pose a posteriori.
Et cet article, qui était truffé d'erreurs,
nous montrait, parce qu'il parlait de Florence aussi, parce que Florence a déposé plainte, non pas contre cet homme, mais contre X pour un compte Twitter sous pseudo qui la harcelait.
Et elle soupçonnait JD d'être derrière ce compte. Mais donc elle a déposé plainte contre X et elle a indiqué aux policiers que ses soupçons se portaient sur JD.
Et donc JD a été interrogé dans le cadre de cette plainte. Et finalement, suite à une absence de collaboration de Twitter,
et la plainte, je sais pas très bien comment on peut appeler ça, mais en tout cas, voilà, on n'a pas pu prouver que c'était lui.
Ça veut pas dire qu'on a prouvé que c'était pas lui, parce que lui, il dit : « J'ai été totalement blanchi, innocenté dans cette histoire », mais ne pas avoir de preuves que c'est quelqu'un, ça ne veut pas dire qu'on a des preuves que c'est pas lui.
Et donc cet article nous montrait Florence et moi en photo,
bien habillées, bien maquillées, dans une pose un peu conquérante, l'air de dire— 'fin, vraiment deux mantes religieuses prêtes à dégoupiller les pauvres pères de famille sans histoire qui rasent les murs.
Ouais, vous êtes présentées comme des élites intellectuelles au-dessus du monde.
Oui, c'est ça.
Voilà, des, des—
Et comme des femmes vénales, menteuses, qui ne supportent pas la critique comme des divas. Voilà, c'est un narratif qui a été beaucoup martelé aussi quoi.
Des divas qui ne supporteraient pas deux, trois moqueries inoffensives sur leur travail.
C'est quand même incroyable quoi, quand on voit les pièces du dossier, comment on peut encore dire que c'est deux, trois moqueries inoffensives sur notre travail, des dégueulasseries immondes.
Qu'est-ce qui peut amener une journaliste à faire ce genre d'article ?
Bah je... c'est juteux, j'imagine.
Peut-être qu'il y a de l'inimitié personnelle, j'en sais rien. Je l'avais... écoute, c'est une journaliste avec qui j'avais fait mon stage à la RTBF Radio Namur quand on avait 20 ans et on s'était assez bien amusées.
Moi, c'était le souvenir que j'avais gardé d'elle, c'est qu'elle était rigolote. Et puis voilà, je la retrouve 15 ans plus tard, à publier des papiers pareils.
Faux surtout. C'est ça qui est quand même assez problématique. C'est qu'en plus ce qui est écrit reste quoi, et donc est partagé, donc alimente aussi des pages Wikipédia puisque c'est considéré comme des sources.
Et pour moi, ça a été... Enfin, c'était terrible. La publication de ce papier, ça a été terrible. Après, je dois bien t'avouer que j'étais habituée.
Je me suis... on s'habitue assez vite, mais je ne me... j'dis pas que pour autant, c'était facile, mais là, ce soir-là, je me suis remise à fumer, par exemple.
Ça faisait plus de huit ans que je fumais plus. Et je, directement, voilà, j'ai lu l'article et j'ai été à l'épicerie m'acheter un paquet de clopes et une bouteille de mauvais vin, un gâteau négro.
J'étais au téléphone avec Florence, je me souviens, on s'est bourré la gueule en fumant. Et j'veux dire, un arrêt du tabac dont je ne suis venue à bout qu'au mois de juillet de cette année.
Donc en 2018, je me suis remise à fumer et fin 2021, j'ai enfin réussi à rearrêter. Donc ça, voilà, c'est tout ça pour dire que j'ai traîné longtemps cette...
Ouais, des impacts sur ta santé physique, mentale, c'est pas rien quoi.
Oui, oui, ben voilà. Donc ça, c'était le premier coup de canif, en fait, dans le contrat de confraternité, j'crois.
T'estimes que l'article a manqué à une certaine éthique, qu'y avait des problèmes en termes de...
Bah oui, déjà, y a plein de trucs qui étaient vérifiables et qui sont faux, alors qu'une simple recherche sur Google, j'pense que tout le monde a Google, hein, aurait permis de...
Mmh.
...au moins ne pas raconter trop de conneries. L'article, il fait 3 000 signes, donc c'est court hein, c'est la moitié d'une page, plus, on va dire deux tiers d'une page Word en Times 12.
Donc c'est pas énorme hein, et 12 erreurs quand même, c'est beaucoup.
Et puis c'est pas des petites erreurs quoi, c'est des erreurs de, 'fin, dire que le harcèlement a lieu de telle année à telle année, alors qu'on trouve très facilement des messages bien postérieurs à ça.
'Fin, c'est assez désespérant quoi. Et puis la manière dont c'était orienté quoi, présenter les victimes comme des coupables.
'Fin, c'était assez dégueulasse. J'ai déposé plainte quelques mois plus tard devant le Conseil de déontologie, après d'abord avoir digéré le truc, parce qu'en fait, 'fin ça m'a vraiment, ça m'a,
'fin ça m'a ébranlée pendant quelques mois, cet article.
Et donc quand je me suis sentie plus solide, j'ai déposé une plainte au Conseil de déontologie journalistique, puisqu'en fait y a que ça à faire quoi.
Parce que j'acceptais pas en fait, j'acceptais pas qu'on écrive des choses pas justes, que, qu'on écrive des critiques.
Vraiment, j'ai l'habitude, je m'en fiche, mais des mensonges, ça, je m'en fiche pas en fait. Surtout quand elles, quand ils sont, quand ils deviennent la version officielle puisqu'ils sont écrits dans le journal.
Et donc quand les gens lisent les choses dans le journal, ils prennent ça pour argent comptant.
Et au Conseil de déontologie, on m'a dit que j'étais arrivée hors délai parce qu'il y avait un délai, ce que j'ignorais puisque je n'avais jamais déposé plainte contre
qui que ce soit et contre quoi que ce soit au Conseil de déontologie.
Mais j'ai dit à partir de là qu'on ne m'y reprendrait plus et que quand je tomberais sur d'autres articles particulièrement problématiques, je déposerai plainte devant le Conseil de déontologie dans les deux mois.
Parce qu'on n'a que deux mois pour le faire, ce que je trouve vraiment très peu, mais j'crois que le Conseil de déontologie est vraiment débordé hein.
Le fait qu'il ait mis deux ans à donner un avis pour une plainte que j'ai déposée contre une autre journaliste, et là, je mets plein de guillemets parce qu'elle est encore moins journaliste que la première,
montre y a quand même un petit problème de,
dans l'arriéré de cet organisme.
Et je ne l'accuse pas hein, mais voilà, cette latence permet de faire proliférer des discours particulièrement néfastes quoi.
Et puis nous, ça nous a, Florence et moi, ça nous a maintenues
dans quelque chose de vraiment sale avant que l'institution dise : « Ben non, en fait,
on peut pas écrire ça parce que c'est faux, parce que c'est pas vérifié, parce qu'y a pas eu le respect du contradictoire, parce que ci, parce que là et parce que c'est un règlement de comptes ».
Mais ça, on en parlera si tu veux. Bon, on peut en parler maintenant...
Non, mais on va en parler maintenant
...parce que ça fait partie en fait des choses qui ont été organisées à l'initiative du harceleur pour me traîner dans la boue.
Donc il a essayé de se trouver des soutiens journalistiques, et il en a trouvé, dont cette journaliste qu'il a contactée.
C'est une journaliste de Pan et de Causeur, qui est donc une publication française très très très à droite. Étonnant.
Et il l'a contactée parce qu'il voyait qu'elle se prenait le bec avec Florence Hainaut sur les réseaux, qu'elles avaient manifestement un contentieux,
et que voilà, il s'est dit : « Oh bah tiens, voilà, je vais lui fournir un truc qui va bien chercher Florence ».
Et ça on le sait parce qu'il l'a dit publiquement.
Ben en fait, c'est elle qui l'a dit publiquement puisque j'ai déposé plainte au Conseil de déontologie et que dans son audition, c'est ce qu'elle raconte.
Audition qui est disponible sur Internet hein, vous pouvez aller voir sur lecdj.be, y a 15 pages de rapport qui sont absolument édifiantes, parce que cette personne vit dans une réalité qui n'est pas tout à fait la nôtre.
Ouais, on explique que tu as horreur des personnes de couleur, c'est ça ?
Oui, c'est ça, que je serais raciste. Non, non, c'est pas ça. Que justement, je me réclame de l'antiracisme, mais que je ne laisse pas entrer des personnes de couleur, qui dit encore de couleur, dans ma vie.
Je ne me mêle pas à ces gens-là, dit-elle. Y a aussi une histoire que je trouve pas mon point G.
D'accord. Que je serais pro idéologie trans, dit-elle, pro voile islamique et pro j'sais plus quoi et que donc je dois être combattue.
Et donc c'est en tant que citoyenne engagée qu'elle me combat et non en tant que journaliste, parce qu'elle dit que son papier n'a pas été écrit en tant que journaliste, mais en tant que citoyenne engagée.
Et elle explique aussi qu'elle l'a fourni gratuitement au journal Pan,
Et c'est pour ça que ça a été accepté
...qu'elle a refusé de se faire payer. Et que c'est pour ça que ça a été accepté. Le Pan, donc y a des éch-, un--
le CDJ, le Conseil de déontologie publie
les échanges que le
journal a eus avec la journaliste et où il dit : « Bon, le rédacteur en chef, d'habitude, je suis pas
très favorable au règlement de comptes dans mes colonnes, mais bon, puisque tu ne souhaites pas te faire payer, ben au moins, ça nous fait un contenu à publier gratuitement ».
Et voilà, donc ça a été publié gratuitement. Et donc deux ans plus tard, le Conseil de déontologie a bien déterminé que tous les points sur lesquels nous attaquions cette journaliste étaient en frein.
Sauf la confraternité, ça, c'est un truc assez difficile à comprendre. Donc, et je pense que sur neuf points que nous avions soulevés, on a gain de cause sur les huit points, sauf sur la confraternité.
Donc le... 'fin c'est officiellement un règlement de comptes, c'est ce que le CDJ écrit, mais publier un règlement de comptes ne serait pas une infraction à la confraternité.
Donc voilà. Parce que la confraternité est inscrite dans la Charte de déontologie journalistique. Et c'est un principe qui moi m'est assez cher.
Ça veut pas dire qu'on peut pas critiquer les confrères, ça veut pas dire qu'on peut pas enquêter sur eux, mais on ne règle pas ses comptes quoi.
Enfin, c'est pas comme ça que ça fonctionne.
Donc là on a parlé d'une espèce de fiction qui parlait de toi et Florence...
Oui enfin ça dit que c'est une fiction puis ça dit que c'est la vérité puis elle l'a envoyé à la moitié de son réseau en disant : « Voici mon enquête sur l'affaire Hainaut-Leroy ».
Elle en a fait une vidéo aussi, vidéo qui a été reprise sur le site de Causeur, puis elle a aussi fait une interview de mon harceleur dans Causeur.
Et puis enfin bref, Causeur a beaucoup, beaucoup roulé...
Oui oui tout à fait oui, l'interview du harceleur dans Causeur. Quand j'avais lu ça, c'était mon...
donc en fait pendant longtemps, on en parlait de manière très, très sommaire avec toi et je ne connaissais absolument pas le nom de la personne.
C'est harceleur présumé à l'époque.
Oui. Bah non, mais moi, je donne son nom jamais en fait. J'ai pris l'habitude de ne jamais donner son nom pour qu'on puisse rien me reprocher.
Je disais cette pseudo interview dans Causeur...
Ah ouais.
...du harceleur présumé à l'époque, présumé...
Oui.
...aujourd'hui vérifié.
Reconnu, patenté.
Voilà, c'est ça. Et en fait je l'imaginais genre tu sais, baraqué, skinhead et tout. Et...
Non.
...ouais quand je l'ai vu au procès en...
...il était très, très fin.
C'est une croquette hein, on peut le dire.
Et aussi surtout, on parlait tout à l'heure d'un article qui a couvert l'affaire dans Le Vif.
Ouais.
Ça encore, ça a été publié, je pense en octobre ou novembre,
2019. Enfin bref, à un moment où y avait pas d'actualité judiciaire, où j'attendais la fixation des plaidoiries, je crois, ou une décision, mais qui allait pas tomber tout de suite.
Enfin bref, c'était très étrange d'écrire un article maintenant sur cette affaire qui n'avait pas vraiment d'actualité, qui suivait son cours de manière très lente hein, comme la justice, on a l'habitude.
Et j'ai eu un coup de fil d'une journaliste du Vif qui me demandait de réagir, elle me dit qu'elle a interrogé mon harceleur et me demandait de réagir à cette interview.
Et moi, j'ai dit : « Non, non, non, mais non, pourquoi ? Enfin. Oh non, please, n'écrivez rien, surtout pas ». Elle me dit : « Mais si, si, c'est déjà en cours, quatre pages, on va publier ».
Quatre pages, mais pourquoi ? Et pourquoi maintenant ? Elle me dit : « Ah ben en fait, c'est parce qu'un célèbre blogueur bruxellois...
Mmm-hmm.
...donc qui n'est pas mon harceleur, qui est un autre, a appelé Le Vif, les a contactés et leur a dit : « J'ai un dossier explosif sur Myriam Leroy, je vais vous le balancer ».
J'aurais bien couvert l'affaire moi-même, mais en fait ça va détruire sa carrière, ça va probablement détruire celle de Florence Hainaut aussi.
Et moi, je m'expose à des représailles, voilà, beaucoup trop sévères si je m'en charge moi-même sur mon blog. Donc voilà. Et donc
son dossier explosif qui allait détruire nos carrières, c'est la fameuse version du harceleur
qui est martelée partout par la journaliste de Pan, par les gens de Causeur, c'est-à-dire, en résumé, elle n'a jamais été harcelée, mais c'est elle la harceleuse quoi, en gros.
Oui que tout ça, c'est un vaste projet entrepreneurial pour vous construire de la fame, de la notoriété...
Ouais.
...et capitaliser là-dessus en...
Voilà.
...publiant un roman, en faisant une pièce de théâtre...
Ouais.
...en produisant un docu. Tout ça, c'est...
Ouais c'est ça.
...on se pose en victime et on s'enrichit, on capitalise, on fait plein de thunes.
Oui, oui. Une victime, voilà, ce serait pour obtenir cet avantageux statut de victime, parce que c'est vrai que c'est super d'être une victime, on est très content, c'est glamour en plus.
Moi, depuis que je suis née, je me dis : « Putain, moi plus tard, je serai une victime, c'est trop cool ». Mais ça marche, c'est un narratif qui marche, très bien même, et pas uniquement pour moi.
Je veux dire, en général, toute femme qui à un moment donné cesse d'être un paillasson et dépose plainte ou affiche soit son agresseur, soit... enfin voilà, qui parle simplement.
Toute femme qui parle, tôt ou tard, et souvent assez tôt, se fera traiter de
femme vénale qui cherche à se faire du pognon et de la célébrité sur base de ses agressions, qui veut juste briser la carrière de pauvres hommes.
Oui, alors on va revenir là-dessus dans un instant parce que c'est très intéressant, mais ce que je voulais dire sur cet article dans Le Vif, c'est deux choses.
Premièrement, il est comme toujours présenté par ses initiales...
Ouais et moi toujours avec mon nom.
...et on donne pas son identité. Oui, mais voilà, mais tu es une figure publique, tu n'as pas le droit à...
Oui voilà, c'est ça.
...à pouvoir rester discrète. Et je me souviens qu'à l'époque, tu ne m'avais pas donné son nom, je ne connaissais pas son nom.
Et je me souviens que juste en dessous du tweet du Vif, bah y avait lui, avec son nom complet, qui se plaignait, qui parlait de son injustice, etc.
Oui, lui il en fait depuis le début hein, depuis qu'il sait que... enfin,
même bien avant que mon roman Les yeux rouges sorte, bien avant qu'il soit imprimé, et qu'il a eu vent du fait qu'il y avait un livre en préparation sur la thématique du harcèlement,
il publiait déjà des tweets en cascade en disant : « Ah, enfin un livre qui va parler de moi.
Alors j'espère que si y a un film, on est un jour tiré, je serai joué par machin ou machin, mais surtout pas par machin.
Et quant à toi, trucmuche, tu peux t'attendre à être jouée par Bouli Lanners et gna, gna, gna ». Voilà, donc en fait, lui, c'est un passe-temps hein, c'est un jeu, c'est un plaisir.
C'est un plaisir d'être identifié comme étant un harceleur.
Il prétend s'en amuser, en tout cas. Et...
Il attire l'attention beaucoup sur lui. Voilà, personne ne saurait qui c'est si lui ne le faisait pas, si lui ne criait pas : « C'est moi, c'est moi le harceleur de Myriam Leroy ».
Tout à fait. Et je peux vérifier ça puisque c'est grâce à lui-même que je sais qui il est.
Voilà.
Dans l'article, il est aussi évoqué que toujours dans cette idée que c'est un faux harcèlement et que tout ça, c'est construit de toutes pièces,
il est question de ces idées comme quoi y a eu un piratage de ton adresse IP, un piratage de ta connexion Internet.
Alors, Florence a donc
été la cible d'un compte Twitter anonyme qui la harcelait. Elle suspectait JD, et à l'aide d'un ami à qui touchait sa bille en informatique
Elle a envoyé au profil officiel de JD un lien à cliquer et sur ce faux compte, qui... enfin, ce vrai compte, mais sous pseudo qui l'a harcelé, le même lien à cliquer.
Genre : « Wow, une vidéo de toi circule sur Internet. » Ou enfin, tu vois, ce genre de... j'sais pas comment ça s'appelle en fait, toi qui touche d'habits aussi en informatique, tu dois savoir même.
Quoi ? Du phishing ?
Ouais, c'est peut-être ça. Enfin, en tout cas, pour obtenir l'adresse IP de quelqu'un, s'il clique sur une adresse.
Et donc il se fait que c'est la même adresse IP qui a cliqué, dans les messages privés de JD officiel, sous son nom et dans les messages privés de ce compte sous pseudo.
Et donc Florence a donné cette adresse IP aux enquêteurs et les enquêteurs, un jour, ils sont venus chez moi,
toujours pour m'auditionner dans le cadre de cette affaire, simplement prendre la confirmation de ma plainte ou j'sais pas quoi,
et m'ont dit en fin d'entretien que manifestement, mon réseau informatique avait été piraté parce que l'adresse IP qu'ils avaient remontée menait jusqu'à chez moi. Voilà.
Pam pam pam. Et comment est-ce que tu expliques ça ?
Ben, alors soit ils ont fait une erreur et soit Florence a fait une erreur.
Ouais, ouais.
Soit son ami a fait une erreur, soit j'ai été piratée. Et bon, je vois pas très bien... soit je suis folle, somnambule, voilà, j'ai différentes personnalités.
Voilà, je n'en sais rien. Je n'en sais pas plus parce qu'y a... les devoirs d'enquête se sont arrêtés là en fait.
Mais donc cette absurdité est brandie depuis des années par JD et par ses complices pour dire : « Ah ben voilà, vous voyez, faux harcèlement, elles se harcèlent l'une l'autre » et, mais enfin, et ça ne leur effleure pas l'esprit que...
Ça revient encore même après que le verdict soit tombé.
Tout à fait, tout à fait.
Que c'est l'histoire que voilà, elles se harcèlent l'une l'autre, vous êtes toutes les deux tarées et qu'il faut aucune sympathie à votre égard.
Ouais, mais comme si... enfin, les adresses IP, je sais bien que ça se remonte. Enfin, là, je suis en train de me justifier et de prouver que c'est pas moi qui ai harcelé Florence.
Mais enfin, ce serait vraiment bizarre de faire une sorte de coup conjoint avec ma propre adresse IP sans essuyer mes traces. Enfin,
je suis pas un génie de l'informatique, mais j'suis pas tout à fait débile non plus quoi. Je sais qu'on laisse des traces partout où on va sur Internet et que cliquer sur... enfin voilà,
qu'un faux compte Twitter sous pseudo,
ça se remonte assez facilement si la volonté...
Si Twitter coopère.
Ouais, si Twitter coopère et s'il y a une volonté policière et puis les moyens aussi de remonter jusque-là. Donc y a de ça.
Et il se fait que moi, ils ont inspecté évidemment mes connexions puisqu'ils sont remontés jusqu'à moi.
Et ces jours-là, outre le fait que j'étais pas en Belgique,
et donc j'pouvais pas vraiment surfer depuis ma connexion, y a eu des connexions à ma connexion qui était pourtant privée et sécurisée et avec mot de passe, machin.
Donc je vois des, j'sais pas, des types là, Thomas machin, qui s'est connecté à mon wifi. Oui, c'est assez particulier.
Mmh. OK.
J'ai fait inspecter ça à des amis informaticiens qui m'ont dit qu'en fait, en l'état, ils ont pas assez d'informations pour pouvoir dire c'que c'est.
Mais ça ressemble à quelqu'un qui a mon mot de passe. Mais non, je ne donne pas, moi, le mot de passe de mon wifi à des inconnus qui habitent à Torbec.
Mmh. Mystère.
Ouais, bref, mystère. Et en fait, je vais pas m'épuiser à essayer. Si la police veut continuer les devoirs d'enquête, ça m'arrangerait évidemment, parce que ça montrerait que cette version est tellement conne.
Mais y a voilà, quelques petits trucs comme ça qui sont bien venus me faire chier et qui sont... parce que c'est venu leur donner
des arguments fous, mais en fait, ils s'en foutent hein, que ce soit vraisemblable, que ça ait un rapport, que ça réponde à des questions de type a priori sur le crime ou pas.
Du moment que ça a l'air un peu glauque, un peu tordu, ça ajoute de l'eau au moulin de leur narratif. Y a aussi eu le fait qu'un des
messages particulièrement hors durée qui m'avait été adressé l'avait été via un formulaire de contact de plusieurs sites.
J'ai fourni aux policiers l'adresse IP de l'envoyeur, enfin de l'auteur des messages, qui était évidemment la même, qui m'a été fournie par les administrateurs de ces deux sites.
Et les policiers n'ont pas remonté les adresses IP. Ils ont pris l'adresse mail que l'auteur avait renseignée. C'est-à-dire que dans un des cadres, il était mis, enfin, y avait une obligation de renseigner une adresse mail.
Mais on pouvait dire n'importe quoi. On pouvait dire : « Tire-lui pinpon sur le chihuahua @vatfairefoutre.com » ou, là, en l'occurrence, le mec, c'était : « ta gueule
@hotmail.com » ou un truc du style, parce que dans ses messages, il disait : « Ta gueule, ta gueule, ta gueule ».
Le titre de son message, c'était : « Ta gueule ». Voilà. Et donc c'est une adresse évidemment farfelue, un truc inventé pour l'occasion. Et
il se fait qu'ils ont remonté cette adresse et que cette adresse a été créée au Canada dans les années 90, et que là, pour JD et ses défenseurs, c'est devenu
: « Putain, en fait, c'est son ex qui la harcèle depuis le Canada », parce qu'il se fait que mon ex est de nationalité canadienne.
Et donc c'est devenu une adresse créée dans le bled de naissance de Dan Gagnon. Non, mais tu sais, c'est grand quand même le Canada déjà.
Et puis cette adresse est une fausse adresse.
Voilà. C'est pas, c'était pas ça qu'il fallait remonter. Mais alors là, ça alimente leur version parce que j'imagine que ça donne de moi une image de quelqu'un d'harcelé par tout le monde.
Donc si je suis autant harcelée, c'est que je suis hautement harcelable. Et y a quelque chose de, voilà, qui vient corroborer un pressentiment de leur part, j'crois.
Le fait que tu sois universellement détestée à travers le monde, ça rendrait finalement leur démarche légitime et ça voudrait dire : « Regardez, voilà, cette personne est controversée. » Enfin voilà.
Oui, oui. Et en plus par son ex, donc c'est vraiment encore plus sale, alors que c'est un ami cher qui est même venu fêter hier avec moi le verdict, le jugement.
Enfin voilà. Et donc ça, c'est les deux points, en fait, les deux biscuits des harceleurs, qui ont été fournis donc par l'enquête de police qui me semble, voilà, un peu problématique.
Et évidemment, j'aimerais qu'on rouvre ce truc pour être totalement, j'allais dire, blanchie, innocentée, mais...
Mmh, ça, ça me paraît...
Mais je pense que ça servirait pas à grand-chose. De toute façon, enfin, quoi qu'il advienne, quoi qu'il arrive, quelles que soient les éventuelles preuves que je pourrais brandir, ces mecs-là, ils s'en foutent complètement.
Ils s'en foutent de la vérité. Tout ce qu'ils veulent, c'est quelque chose pour appuyer leur thèse, leur thèse tordue et masculiniste quoi, c'est tout.
Alors, beaucoup de choses qu'on pourrait commenter. Tu évoquais tout à l'heure que la version, voilà comme tu disais, cette version tordue, masculiniste, de dire que les femmes mentent et qu'elles veulent profiter et que... ça plaît beaucoup.
Y a une grande adhésion à ce postulat, à cette façon de présenter les choses. Comment est-ce que tu l'expliques ? Tu as deux minutes pour répondre.
Est-ce que tu veux que je t'explique des milliers d'années de patriarcat ? Non, mais c'est vieux comme le monde hein, enfin c'est... mais en fait, c'est ça le problème de la misogynie aussi, c'est qu'elle est difficile à expliquer.
Voilà, c'est ce que de Beauvoir disait quoi. C'est pas... Voilà, c'est arrivé. La misogynie, elle est arrivée.
On sait pas comment. On sait que beaucoup de théories, par exemple racistes et négrophobes, ont été inventées assez récemment pour justifier des choses comme la colonisation, la mise en esclavage, etc.
Mais sur la misogynie, on n'a pas d'explication. On n'a pas d'explication. Donc
voilà. Donc je ne peux pas te dire pourquoi nous sommes considérées comme menteuses par,
par définition, par essence, qu'il y a une présomption de culpabilité qui pèse toujours sur les victimes quand ce sont des femmes qui dénoncent leurs agresseurs.
Je peux pas t'expliquer le... voilà, puisqu'en fait, on ne sait pas.
Je vais peut-être présenter la question un peu différemment. Donc là, tu réponds à la question de pourquoi en tant que femme, vous êtes systématiquement blâmées et pourquoi on vous assigne systématiquement des
intentions maléfiques, malveillantes.
La façon dont tu as été dépeinte, enfin, vous avez été dépeintes, toi et Florence, dans l'article de Sud Presse, c'est, voilà, on parlait d'une forme quelque part de
une élite intellectuelle, voilà, les journalistes qui, sur les photos de la RTBF, prennent un air très sûr d'elles, elles regardent le peuple de haut, on se prend pas pour de la merde, etc.
Pourquoi est-ce que, de un, vous êtes vues comme ça ?
Tu veux dire Florence et moi ?
Apparemment. C'est vieux comme le monde, on le sait pas.
Ben moi, j'en sais trop rien. Honnêtement, je sais pas. Je sais que Florence et moi, on a un profil quand même relativement atypique dans les médias belges.
C'est-à-dire que déjà, on est des femmes, hein, et c'est pas si courant dans les médias belges hein. Les rédactions belges, c'est comme Twitter.
Y a que 35 % de femmes. Et la Belgique est un des plus mauvais, je pense même le plus mauvais élève européen en matière de parité dans les rédactions.
Donc on est déjà, rien que par notre existence, des profils atypiques. Et en plus...
J'en ai parlé avec Martine Saumeny y a deux ans, un sérieux plafond de verre, beaucoup de femmes qui quittent la profession très tôt, même si je crois, elles sont majoritaires dans les études.
Dans les écoles, ouais.
Mais...
Ouais, tout à fait
...mais après, elles se barrent parce que...
Parce que c'est pas un milieu très hospitalier pour elles. Ça, je peux en témoigner. Donc déjà, voilà, on est des curiosités à ce niveau-là, rien que par notre existence.
Et puis on éditorialise aussi souvent dans le cadre de notre travail. Moi, c'était surtout dans le cadre de mon travail que je m'exprimais sur des phénomènes de société, sur des sujets.
Je donnais mon avis quoi. Et je donnais mon avis aussi, j'émettais des opinions de nature politique. J'ai participé aussi à beaucoup d'émissions d'humour, d'humour politique.
Et ça, c'est vraiment des endroits où on n'existe pas, où on nous attend pas et où on nous veut pas. Parce que tant qu'on se met, enfin ça, c'est Florence qui dit, quand elle faisait des comparatifs de pots de choco dans
On n'est pas des pigeons, on lui foutait relativement la paix.
Elle avait bien de temps en temps un érotomane qui lui envoyait une dick pic, mais ça s'arrêtait là. C'est déjà pas mal hein, tu vas me dire, mais...
Ouais, ça, moi je ressens pas hein.
Non ? Ah bon. Mais
dès qu'elle s'est mise à faire l'émission politique du dimanche, qui était une place très exposée, très enviée, puis c'était, voilà, elle se piquait de parler de politique et de la gestion de la cité, là, c'est là que sa
vie professionnelle est devenue un calvaire et qu'elle était la cible incessante
d'insultes à caractère sexuel et sexiste en permanence.
Elle coprésentait cette émission avec un journaliste homme à qui on disait : « Vous êtes trop à gauche, monsieur » ou « Vous êtes trop à droite » ou « J'aime pas votre chemise », mais on lui disait pas qu'il avait sucé des bites pour être là.
Florence, oui. Donc voilà, nous, on n'est pas à notre place, si tu veux. Et donc clairement, ça en fait chier beaucoup.
Inconsciemment hein, pas toujours de manière très déclarée,
mais c'est sûr. C'est souvent des femmes, en tout cas les femmes journalistes, les plus harcelées que je connais et qui sont souvent harcelées par des mecs qui me harcèlent moi aussi.
Donc on a une espèce de petite amicale comme ça, par la force des choses,
des cibles des mêmes mecs. C'est souvent des mecs qui supportent pas que les nanas aillent dans un milieu qui est vraiment encore plus fermé aux femmes quoi.
Les journalistes femmes musique, par exemple,
elles s'en prennent mais enfin plein la gueule, mais d'une manière absolument trashissime, parce que ça, c'est vraiment un boys club plus encore que tout le reste quoi, les journalistes qui couvrent la musique.
Surtout en Belgique, c'est vraiment... Enfin, ils sont hardcore, ces mecs-là quoi. Ils se prennent pour des rockeurs, en fait.
C'est cohérent.
Ouais.
Ouais, ce que je veux dire, c'est que j'ai l'impression que cette attaque de « Vous êtes une élite qui crache sur le pauvre peuple » et tout ça...
Non mais ça...
C'est, ça a l'air quasiment automatique
Ça, c'est récurrent
Et je me demande, encore une fois, ouais, d'où est-ce que ça vient ? Comment est-ce que tu analyses ça ?
Bah déjà, les journalistes en général sont considérés comme des élites. 'Fin, on l'a bien vu avec la crise, tout autour des, 'fin, des dérapages autour de certaines manifestations de gilets jaunes.
C'était beaucoup anti-journalistes. On voit encore...
Ouais, ouais
...anti-journalistes aujourd'hui, Eric Bever qui s'est fait, qui a été agressé...
Tout à fait
...dans un parc de manière absolument horrible, en fait...
Ouais, ouais
...avec une...
C'est super proche
...latteine de monde directement dans ses yeux. C'est quel enfer, quelle violence. C'est aussi l'expression d'une rage contre de prétendues élites, alors que vraiment, s'il y a bien un métier, surtout en Belgique,
de précarité, de solitude et de peu de pouvoir, c'est le métier de journaliste.
Donc voilà. Je pense que les femmes aussi, et c'est peut-être sur ce terrain-là que t'as envie de m'amener,
qui ont le luxe de se dresser contre les violences qui leur sont faites, comme moi, parce que c'est un luxe,
sont considérées, et peut-être pas à tort d'ailleurs, comme des bourgeoises hein, parce que je pense que si j'étais plus précaire
dans ce milieu, si... c'est pas pour rien que j'ai attendu si longtemps en fait, avant de déposer plainte et avant, par exemple, de parler, avant d'oser m'exprimer, avant d'oser me dresser.
J'ai attendu, de manière consciente ou pas, un moment de ma vie et de ma carrière où j'avais plus peur de pas avoir à bouffer, de perdre mon boulot, de voir toutes les portes se fermer.
Aujourd'hui, c'est parce que je suis installée en fait et que je sais que quoi qu'il arrive, je rebondirai. 'Fin, je crois que quoi qu'il arrive, je rebondirai
et que j'ai le loisir de pouvoir choisir mes collaborations, de dire non même, et de gagner correctement ma vie.
Donc ça, je peux le faire aujourd'hui, mais et je peux aussi, j'ai le luxe de ne plus être sur Twitter, de ne plus avoir de compte Facebook.
C'est un truc que j'aurais pas pu me permettre si j'étais jeune journaliste, par exemple. Donc voilà. Donc je pense qu'il y a aussi,
souvent les femmes qui, les féministes en fait en général hein, qui luttent contre une oppression ou une injustice qui leur est directement infligée, sont considérées comme des bourgeoises oisives, des dames patronnesses...
Mh
...mais même un peu des bas bleus, tu vois. Y a un peu la, l'accusation...
Ouais
...récurrente d'être : « Elle n'a que ça à foutre ». Sous un article du fameux célèbre blogueur bruxellois qui prend la défense du condamné...
Ah, c'est tellement...
Y a un...
...lié de, plutôt que de dire de ton harceleur, tentons de dire...
Oui
...du condamné.
Le condamné, c'est pas ma... j'aime bien aussi. Y a un mec...
Oui, tout à fait. Donc le criminel, je t'écoute
...qui répond : « Elles nous cassent les pieds avec leur harcèlement. Je plains les gens qui doivent travailler avec la gent féminine.
La plus petite preuve de galanterie, une question sur leur travail, où se trouve tel dossier ? Et paf, c'est plainte pour harcèlement ».
Voilà, je pense que ça illustre bien aussi, j'imagine que c'est aussi, voilà, qu'on nous perçoit comme des élites parce qu'on refuse d'être des paillassons.
Oui, ben, donc les femmes qui ne restent pas à leur place sont...
Ouais
...perçues comme
rebelles, désagréables. Et donc y a un ressentiment par rapport à ces personnes-là qui, alors, tu me diras ce que t'en penses, mais qui ont peut-être aussi les codes pour analyser leur situation, prendre conscience...
Oui
...de l'injustice qui a lieu.
Non, c'est vrai.
Et qui, voilà, qui ont les codes via le prisme du féminisme pour prendre conscience de l'injustice qu'elles traversent.
Donc voilà, ce profil éduqué qui prend conscience de ce qui se passe, c'est perçu comme une idéologie construite, quelque chose de très très bourgeois, très très déconnecté...
Ouais
...une certaine élite. Et voilà, y a beaucoup de mépris...
...par rapport à ça.
Et alors moi, je sais aussi que j'ai une manière de parler assez particulière, qui peut passer pour de la pédanterie.
Mh.
Mais en fait, je sais pas parler autrement. Donc je...
Mh
...j'ai... c'est une histoire, ça, c'est Jérôme Colin qui est l'animateur d'Entrez sans frapper, qui me l'a fait remarquer en fait, parce que moi, je savais pas.
Il m'a dit : « Mais les gens détestent les gens qui parlent comme toi, avec des mots compliqués, élaborés...
Mh
...ils se sentent méprisés par cette manière que tu as de faire ta châtelaine en fait ».
Et ouais, peut-être que ça participe de ça, mais ça, sorry not sorry quoi. Je vais pas m'excuser de ça. Je sais pas faire autrement.
Non mais c'est intéressant. Donc tu ne sais pas faire autrement. Est-ce que si tu savais faire autrement, tu penses que ce serait ta démarche ou bien ?
Non. Mais non, parce qu'en plus, j'ai pas l'impression de m'exprimer de manière cryptée. J'ai juste... j'aime bien la précision quoi.
Et puis je suis pas toujours d'ailleurs. 'Fin, je fais ce que je peux quoi, je m'exprime comme je m'exprime, je m'exprime comme ça me vient, voilà.
Oui, tout à fait.
C'est tout.
Je pense que avant qu'on se rencontre, je me posais aussi la question de savoir : « Tiens, comment va se passer notre conversation ?
Est-ce qu'elle va se prendre pour de la merde ou quelque chose comme ça ? » Et en fait, j'ai très vite compris que, je sais pas, t'avais un rhume, t'étais dans ton canapé en train de tousser.
Oui.
Et j'ai vite constaté que t'étais
Oui
...très très humaine comme moi. Et on a parlé tranquille, à un mètre de distance et t'étais on ne peut plus humaine.
Et je pense qu'effectivement, les gens qui ne te connaissent que via le prisme de,
voilà, de tes chroniques sur La Première où tu parles de ta vie très très privilégiée ou avec des termes, comme tu disais, compliqués, voilà, qui sont pas forcément ceux de monsieur madame Tout-le-monde.
Je peux comprendre qu'ils puissent avoir une vision qui est pas du tout représentative de la personne que tu es vraiment.
Oui, mais, et puis souvent, je veux dire, les chroniques que je faisais à la radio, c'était des chroniques teintées d'humour et en personnage, si tu veux.
'Fin, moi, j'ai fait une chronique qui s'appelait Myriam Leroy n'aime pas pendant un an et demi. Et aujourd'hui encore, on me dit : « Ah non, ne venez pas manger dans mon restaurant, j'ai pas envie qu'on...
» Mais ils le disent pour rire hein, mais : « J'ai pas envie d'avoir un Myriam Leroy n'aime pas mon restaurant demain, à la radio ».
Je fais . Bon alors ça, ça va. Mais quand moi, en tant que journaliste, à côté de ça, parce que c'était une chronique par semaine pendant une saison et une demi-saison, j'ai un vrai boulot.
Enfin, c'est pas ça qui payait mes factures quoi. C'était une petite chronique, j'allais un peu m'amuser quoi, dans une émission jeune, sur une radio jeune.
Mais donc je proposais des reportages, des sujets, des émissions et on me disait : « Non, non, tu vas dire du mal »-- c'est la direction hein qui me disait : « Non, tu vas dire du mal de tes invités, ça ne va pas, tu vas les casser ».
Je me dis : « Attends, non, mais c'est pas, pas... » Y a une immense difficulté, ou alors c'est moi qui suis pas alignée là-dedans, mais à faire la--
parce que moi, j'ai toujours, j'suis toujours partie du principe que c'était en personnage, ces chroniques.
J'suis pas sûr que cette information-là traverse vraiment l'écran.
C'est-à-dire ?
Oui, non, mais ce que j'veux dire, c'est quand tu regardes par exemple sur Ovio, parce que la radio, c'est filmé aujourd'hui, cette information-là de « c'est un personnage »,
Mais-
J'suis sûr que pour tout le monde, on sera conscient
Dans ces chroniques-là en particulier, enfin, c'était tellement plus que du second degré. Enfin, c'était énorme.
C'était outrancier en plus, 'fin. Et puis je faisais même des chroniques genre Myriam Leroy n'aime pas Myriam Leroy, Myriam Leroy n'aime pas l'amour, Myriam Leroy n'aime pas les gens, Myriam Leroy n'aime pas les-- enfin,
je disais souvent des « n'aime pas » de trucs que je faisais et que je pouvais s-- 'fin-
Myriam Leroy n'aime pas les iPhone, tout ça.
Ouais, j'ai eu des menaces de mort d'ailleurs pour cette chronique sur les iPhone. Ouais. Comme quoi. C'est très inattendu en fait, là où les gens placent leur rage.
Ouais, c'est une forme de religion. Oui, on a parlé de traînage dans la boue, on a parlé de couverture dans la presse qui ne te plaisait pas forcément, pour faire un petit euphémisme.
Oui.
Et 'fin, 'fin voilà, tu aurais préféré qu'il y ait un silence médiatique autour de ce dossier ?
Ouais, bah bon, je n'ai pas le bras long qu'on me prête. Donc personne m'a jamais suivie. À chaque fois que j'ai demandé,
de pas publier un truc parce que ça allait me mettre en danger, parce que j'étais pas capable d'encaisser ça à ce moment-là, parce qu'y avait rien à dire, on m'a jamais écoutée.
Mais donc on parle aussi de campagne de harcèlement, de choses qui sont dites à ton sujet sur divers blogs bruxellois.
On a parlé des institutions, des différents journaux, etc. Comment ils se placent vis-à-vis du harcèlement des femmes journalistes.
Mais plus précisément, tes consœurs, tes confrères, est-ce que tu as vécu une certaine solidarité ? Est-ce que tu as vécu un manque de solidarité de leur part ?
Bah, ça dépend qui, ça dépend quand aussi. Plus on avance, je trouve, plus je reçois des manifestations de solidarité que j'avais pas du tout avant.
Alors là, quand j'ai eu un raid énorme en 2013 qui a carrément foutu ma vie par terre-
Mmm-hmm. On en avait parlé y a trois ans, ouais
...c'était-- franchement, je les compte sur les doigts du-- demi doigts d'une main, doigts d'une demi main, les manifestations de solidarité dans la profession.
Aujourd'hui, c'est différent parce qu'aussi, je pense qu'il y a une prise de conscience de la dimension purement misogyne et donc politique des attaques qui me sont adressées, 99 % du temps hein.
Et que voilà, les gens sont-- les journalistes prennent conscience de ça, peut-être en retard même sur la société, même peut-être en retard même sur la justice, mais voilà, prennent conscience de ça.
Mais oui, globalement, pas énormément de soutien, pas énormément de confraternité, on l'a dit, et même parfois carrément des actes hostiles quoi.
Comme un journaliste qui s'appelle d'ailleurs Frédéric Bréban, lui, je vois pas pourquoi j'irais pas le nommer,
qui a organisé une campagne de désinscription à l'Association des journalistes professionnels parce qu'il refusait que ses cotisations servent à payer nos frais de justice à Florence et moi.
Et donc voilà, il dit : « Ça fait 30 ans que je suis affilié. Là, vraiment, c'est la goutte d'eau qui fait déborder le vase ».
Et donc il a été retweeté abondamment par des confrères aussi, par des consœurs. Et voilà. Et ça, c'est particulièrement-- alors, je m'en fous de ce mec, je le connais pas, à moitié pas.
Mmm.
Je vois qu'il sait, mais-
Mais est-ce que tu t'en fous des retweets aussi ? Donc les nombreux, les nombreuses confrères et consœurs qui l'ont retweeté.
Ouais, mais la démarche quoi. Comment t'es pas gêné d'organiser une campagne de désinscription à ton union professionnelle parce qu'elle soutient des femmes journalistes harcelées dans le cadre de leur boulot ?
Et lui, il estime que vraiment l'AJP a perdu le sens des priorités, que c'est pas ça qu'il faut faire, sans évidemment indiquer quelles seraient lesdites priorités qui auraient ces faveurs quoi.
Mais ça, alors c'était pas dur à vivre parce qu'en fait, voilà, je suis-- en fait, au fil du temps, je me suis habituée à ce genre de coups bas, mais quand même, je trouve ça étonnant.
Je trouve que à ce point résister au sens de l'histoire, à ce point résister à un combat qui est évidemment collectif.
Moi, j'irai pas en justice pour restau-- j'irai pas en justice pour restaurer mon honorabilité. 'Fin, j'y vais parce que
il me semble que c'est un problème, un phénomène de société, un problème qui nous regarde tous et que ça peut être bénéfique en fait à l'ensemble de la profession
de voir, mettre quelques balises quand même à ce qui peut être dit d'insultes et de menaces aux journalistes et aux individus en général.
Donc ça fait partie des trucs-- mais enfin, le nombre--
j'ai perdu le compte en fait. À un moment donné, j'avais pris une sorte de, fait une sorte de journal de bord de toutes les dégueulasseries qui m'avaient été faites quoi,
notamment de la part de confrères,
surtout des confrères hein, on va pas se mentir.
Mais puis j'ai arrêté parce qu'en fait ça me prenait un temps con et puis ça-- voilà, sinon ça tourne trop obsessionnellement dans mon crâne quoi.
Mais en fait, ces mecs, ils font ça, donc c'est-à-dire des campagnes de désinscription à l'AJP, mais aussi des campagnes de dénigrement, je pense à d'autres journalistes, alors que c'est à peu près des nobody.
Hein, je veux dire, ils ont pas énormément de pouvoir, c'est pas de l'abus de pouvoir. Mais malgré le fait qu'ils soient des nobody, ils auront quand même toujours plus de pouvoir que nous.
En tout cas, ils reçoivent leur permis de harceler, leur permis de nous bâcher, leur permis de nous traîner dans la boue.
Ils y sont autorisés parce que leurs rédacteurs en chef s'en foutent, parce que la société s'en fout. Et voilà, pourquoi-- c'est toujours la même question : pourquoi les hommes agressent ?
Pourquoi des hommes agressent ? Ce serait sans doute plus juste, mais voilà.
Est-ce que tu vas nous faire un hashtag NotAllMen ?
Je viens de faire un hashtag Not All Men, mais notamment parce que je pense que tu me l'avais reproché une fois de dire les hom-- c'est pas toi qui as fait ça ?
J'avais dit : « Les hommes agressent » et tu m'avais dit : « Non, mais attention, pas tous, pas... »
Je pense pas.
Non ?
J'ai dit beaucoup de conneries dans notre entretien, dans notre première rencontre il y a trois ans. Je pense pas que j'ai dit ça.
Non ? Ah bon, merde, pardon.
Tu me prêtes de mauvaises intentions, tu me refiles la patate chaude. Et en plus, ça sous-entendrait que j'ai réussi à te convaincre de ça.
Je me plie à tes volontés. Doxa Not All Meniste. Frédéric Bréban, il fait cette campagne parce qu'il sait que ça n'aura pas de conséquences.
C'est ça le problème. C'est l'inertie, en fait, de l'ensemble de la société. Leurs agressions à eux, finalement, c'est pas que c'est pas grave, c'est désagréable, c'est jamais chouette, mais
c'est que les gens qui sont censés siffler la fin de la récré regardent ailleurs tout simplement, même quand on leur dit : « Eh, je pense que ça, hein, ton journaliste, là,
il me fait chier toute la journée, il critique mon boulot alors qu'on bosse pour le même magazine.
Enfin, c'est quand même un peu bizarre. » C'est aussi un peu la réputation de ton journal qui est en cause quand il dit : « Machin travaille comme une merde.
» « Oh non, non, ça ne me regarde pas. D'ailleurs, je n'ai rien vu, je ne suis pas sur les réseaux sociaux. » C'est ça qu'ils nous disent, les rédacteurs en chef.
Et en plus, tu es freelance, donc je ne peux vraiment rien pour toi. Ah putain, c'est génial d'être freelance, en fait. Super.
Est-ce que je peux te demander, donc voilà, toutes ces campagnes de harcèlement, de dénigrement de ta personne.
T'expliquais que c'était très dur à vivre en termes de santé mentale et même de poumon dans ton cas. Est-ce que je peux te demander ce que tu as mis en place pour mieux vivre ça, pour survivre à ça ?
Oh ben, on va pas se le cacher, je prends des médicaments hein, et j'augmente fréquemment la dose.
D'accord. OK. Je ne voulais pas nécessairement être intrusif à ce point-là.
Non, non, mais moi, j'ai pas-- je suis assez prosélyte en fait sur les médicaments.
Tout à fait.
Je suis une fan de médicaments.
C'est très bien. Ouais, ouais. Tu as très bien parlé de la question des antidépresseurs dans-
Ouais
...ton interview avec Fanny Ruwet dans « Les Gens qui doutent ».
Oui, moi, j'ai aucun problème à parler de ça. Je prends-- toutes les femmes harcelées, via des moyens numériques, font part de la même
expérience de l'angoisse et des attaques de panique, de la difficulté à prendre les transports en commun, par exemple, ou de se retrouver dans une foule.
Et on vit toutes ça. Et oui, j'avais des attaques de panique vachement invalidantes et certaines molécules, les inhibiteurs sélectifs de la recapture de la sérotonine qui sont vachement efficaces pour ça.
Et il se fait que maintenant, je suis en pleine réflexion parce que je pense m'en passer à court terme, pour remplacer ça par un traitement aux psychédéliques, figure-toi.
Donc ça m'intéresserait beaucoup que tu fasses un podcast là-dessus parce qu'il y a pas assez de connaissances en Belgique là-dessus et que j'ai un
peu peur de me retrouver coincée dans un bad trip, mais certaines substances psychédéliques auraient un pouvoir
carrément de restauration en fait.
Mais oui, je veux bien que tu me files le numéro de ton dealer pour une interview alors.
D'accord, ouais. Bah, il est flamand.
Zut.
Donc les médicaments. Aussi, ben, sortir des réseaux sociaux, avoir killé mon compte Facebook et mon compte Twitter, ça m'a permis de conserver un semblant de santé mentale, même si ça-
Instagram, c'est mieux en termes de santé mentale ?
Ouais, ouais. Même si ça fait pas disparaître hein, le harcèlement. On peut très bien être harcelé sans avoir la moindre existence numérique hein.
Je veux dire, ma page Wikipédia, c'est pas moi qui l'ai faite,
mais euh-- donc je ne vais absolument jamais la voir, parce qu'en fait chaque fois que je vais la voir, c'est-à-dire une fois toutes les x années,
y a une énorme connerie écrite par quelqu'un qui souhaite manifestement me nuire et ruiner ma réputation.
Et je me retrouve parfois en interview dans des pays où auprès de gens qui ne me connaissent pas et qui se basent donc vraiment 100 % sur la page Wikipédia pour brosser mon portrait en amorce d'interview.
Et je fais : « Mais de où ? Hein ? Quoi ? » Ben, je me rends compte qu'en fait c'est à cause des conneries que ces mecs ont été foutre sur Wikipédia.
Donc un pas de côté sur les réseaux sociaux.
Ouais, un pas de côté des réseaux sociaux. Mais ça, je pense que c'est bénéfique à la santé mentale en général, parce que c'est trop de sollicitations en fait, c'est quand même très difficile à gérer.
Et puis, bien s'entourer. Et puis aussi, me redresser la barre professionnellement parlant. Moi, j'ai été-- même si mon union professionnelle, je la remercierai jamais assez pour le soutien qu'elle m'a accordé.
Et mes meilleurs amis sont jo-- quasi tous journalistes, mais j'ai été quand même vraiment dégoûtée
de la profession en général, de la manière dont ça s'est passé, mais depuis le départ hein, je veux dire, de toutes les
choses qui se sont écrites sur moi par rapport notamment au raid que j'ai vécu en 2013, ont été particulièrement, ben paresseuses intellectuellement, dangereuses même, et nuisibles.
Et j'aime beaucoup ce métier, j'aime beaucoup des gens qui font ce métier, mais en général, moi, c'est un milieu dans lequel je me sens plus du tout la bienvenue et donc je me casse.
Et mon métier de journaliste, je l'exerce à côté quoi, c'est-à-dire faire un documentaire, donc plus travailler pour une rédaction.
C'est aussi écrire une pièce de théâtre documentaire dans une logique journalistique, avec des techniques journalistiques.
Et voilà, c'est comme ça que j'estime faire un boulot de journaliste aujourd'hui.
Tu aimes le journalisme, tu aimes être journaliste, mais les médias belges en général t'ont fortement déçue.
Mhm.
Est-ce que tu peux nous parler, enfin spécifiquement, donc toi, tu faisais des chroniques sur La Première où tu exprimais, voilà, une prise de position concernant l'actualité.
Tu l'as fait en tout cas à quelques occasions.
Ouais.
Tu ne le fais plus aujourd'hui.
Non.
C'est quoi ? C'est-- la RTBF t'a déçue aussi-
Ah oui
...à ce niveau-là ?
Ouais, alors la RTBF, j'ai encore une-- enfin, je reviens cette année, une fois toutes les deux semaines faire un petit jeu dans l'émission de Jérôme Colin parce que c'est amusant et voilà.
Mais c'est pas du tout une surface d'expression, un caractère politique, pas du tout. Et
je le ferai plus. J'irai plus m'exprimer sur des médias grand public parce qu'on n'y prend encore pas du tout la mesure de ce que c'est s'exprimer quand on est une femme et que la dernière fois
C'était au mois de septembre de l'année dernière.
Je faisais une chronique tous les X, j'pense tous les mois, dans une émission animée par Pascal Claude. Et il se fait que, dans une chronique où je parlais de Twitter, de la violence qui régnait sur Twitter,
j'ai fait une petite blague, un petit tacle à Damien Ernst qui est, comment peut-on le définir ?
Un animal médiatique, professionnel de Twitter et aussi-
Il est professeur à Liège, voilà. Dans l'ordre, il est d'abord professeur à Liège et puis il va aussi sur Twitter.
C'est ça. Et il se spécialise dans le nucléaire, voilà.
C'est ça. Et il est très pro nucléaire dans les idées qu'il exprime. Et il est pro d'autres choses.
Ouais, c'est ça.
Et il tweete tout le temps en surjouant une espèce d'ingénuité. 'Fin, voilà.
Et donc j'avais fait une petite blague en disant que, bah, il était temps d'arrêter avec Twitter, de tirer la prise, de supprimer en fait la plateforme parce que Twitter, c'était un peu comme le nucléaire.
À un moment donné, on a cru que ça allait nous emmener vers le futur, nous sauver la vie, etc., etc. Et in fine, on remarque que ça donne surtout l'occasion de s'exprimer à Damien Ernst.
Voilà. Et moi, je trouvais que c'était une bonne petite blague, certes gratuite, mais pas tant que ça. Je trouvais qu'elle avait quand même du sens. Et-
Ça n'avait pas plu à tout le monde. Je me souviens notamment que une politicienne, comment elle s'appelle ? CDH.
Oui, Catherine Fonck, qui m'avait traitée d'obscurantiste anti-science. Waouh ! Elle dit qu'elle voit pas le rapport.
OK, d'accord.
Oui, ça avait f-- donc ça avait créé un énorme tollé et j'avais vécu une petite vague de harcèlement et d'insultes suite à ça.
Et en fait, ça m'a été reproché par la direction de la RTBF d'avoir fait une blague sur Damien Ernst. Ça se faisait pas.
Spécifiquement parce que c'était Damien Ernst ?
Ouais, j'crois. J'sais pas. Parce qu'en fait j'ai pas vraiment voulu creuser. Ça m'a tellement désespérée que-- et là, j'ai dit que je reviendrais pas, en fait.
Et donc je ne suis plus revenue. J'ai fait deux chroniques cette année-là et puis je suis plus revenue, aussi parce que j'avais un documentaire à tourner et autre chose à faire et que j'étais pas-- en fait, j'avais pas envie.
J'avais pas envie de faire de la radio, et certainement pas dans des conditions pareilles, mais qu'on me reproche d'avoir fait une blague sur Damien Ernst qui justifierait toutes les outrances des auditeurs.
Mmh, ouais. Victime, victim blaming, quoi.
'Fin, oui, c'est ça.
On met la faute sur la victime.
J'me suis dit : « Quoi, on en est encore là en 2000-- » c'était en 2020. Et là, j'me suis dit : « Non, en fait, ça suffit, ça suffit ».
Et donc je me suis cassée et voilà ce que je peux dire sur cette affaire.
Et qu'est-ce que tu aurais attendu précisément, voilà, d'une institution comme la RTBF ? Qu'elle te soutienne publiquement ?
Qu'elle affiche publiquement-
Non, non. Parce qu'en fait, il f-- je pense que c'est vraiment pas ce qu'on cherche, du soutien ou des pouces et de love.
C'est l'instauration d'un truc au sein du boulot, en s-- de prendre conscience que c'est un accident du travail.
Je pense que n'importe quel professionnel qui serait menacé et insulté quotidiennement dans le cadre de ses fonctions, dans n'importe quel autre métier, y aurait des garde-fous qui seraient mis en place ou ne fût-ce qu'une réflexion.
J'veux dire, si un employé de La Poste était tous les jours agressé par un usager mécontent, peut-être que son patron penserait que ça le regarde aussi, qu'y aurait peut-être quelque chose à réfléchir.
Et surtout si tous les employés de La Poste sont agressés tous les matins par des usagers mécontents ou tous les employés d'un certain profil parce que voilà.
Et donc c'est ça, plutôt que d'avoir « nous soutenons notre journaliste », c'est avoir une modération quoi, une vraie bonne modération adéquate, ne pas faire des articles à pots ou à trolls,
en extrayant des extraits qui, hors contexte, peuvent être les plus polémiques pour en faire les titres, par exemple.
'Fin, en tout cas, y a toute une réflexion à avoir parce qu'on sait maintenant, on le voit, quand on prend la parole dans l'espace public et qu'on est
une personne issue d'une minorité ou une personne minorisée, ben ça se passe dans la violence quoi.
Et c'est pour ça. 'Fin, est-ce qu'y a encore aujourd'hui-- 'fin, je voyais un statut Facebook de la poétesse Lisette Lombé, dont je recommande le recueil Brûlez, brûlez, brûlez, qui est sorti à l'Iconopop.
On m'a envoyé un de ses posts Facebook où elle disait que dès qu'elle était apparue sur Vivacité, dès que ses chroniques, parce qu'elle a fait une éphémère chronique sur la première, elle avait été la cible d'insultes et de haters.
Et c'était la première fois de sa vie, en fait, qu'elle était confrontée à ça et que ça l'a immédiatement convaincue de ne plus foutre les pieds à la radio.
Voilà. Voilà ce qui se passe, en fait. Ça fait que ça, ça fait plus de chroniques féministes le matin. Y a plus, en fait, y a plus.
Y a plus de voix féministes à la RTBF aujourd'hui, tu dirais ?
Pas que je sache, en tout cas. Mais moi, ça fait quand même un bout de temps que j'écoute plus trop la radio de flux parce que ce qui s'y dit m'intéresse pas, voilà, tout simplement.
C'est toujours les mêmes qui disent toujours la même chose. Moi, je vais plutôt écouter des podcasts quoi, si j'ai envie de mettre un truc dans mes oreilles.
Quelle bonne idée. Oui, mais ce que tu me dis, ça fait complètement écho à ce que disait Marie Peltier dans le podcast qu'on a enregistré y a un peu plus d'un an avec Florence Hainaut aussi.
Plutôt que d'afficher un soutien et de dire à la victime ou à la cible de harcèlement qu'on est trop avec toi, on-- c'est super ce que tu fais, t'inquiète pas trop s'il y a des gens qui t'embêtent.
Faudrait peut-être plutôt remettre en place les agresseurs et les harceleurs et-
Oui, et souvent, y a des harceleurs au sein des rédactions, au sein des médias mêmes. Donc y a peut-être des formations aussi à mettre en place.
Moi, je serais aussi très partisane de l'instauration d'une charte que tous les employés et les intervenants aussi indépendants s'engagent à respecter.
C'est ce qui se fait déjà dans le milieu de l'édition, par exemple, des chartes qui disent : « Voilà, je m'engage à ne pas harceler mes collègues.
» Et je m'expose à être renvoyé sans autre forme de procès. Enfin si, avec une petite forme de procès quand même, mais si je contreviens à cette disposition quoi.
Ça se fait dans plein de milieux professionnels aujourd'hui.
Voilà toute ma question. Ça se fait dans plein d'endroits. Pourquoi pas dans les rédactions des-
Bah parce qu'ils s'en foutent. Parce que
les-- parce qu'il y a peu de femmes, parce que les rédacteurs en chef, c'est des hommes, parce qu'ils vivent pas ça, parce que c'est pas une priorité pour eux et parce qu'ils sont traversés, comme nous tous hein, par des biais, des préjugés
sexistes et misogynes quoi, tout simplement.
Mmmh mmmh mmmh.
C'est que des histoires de bonnes femmes hein pour eux, c'est pas important, c'est pas grave.
Alors on s'approche tout doucement de la fin de cet entretien. Un petit commentaire et tu me diras ce que t'en penses.
Une analyse que je voudrais peut-être proposer, c'est que, voilà, tu nous parles de tous ces hommes qui harcèlent sur les réseaux sociaux.
Tu évoquais un mépris particulièrement pour les journalistes ces dernières années avec la crise des Gilets jaunes, la crise sanitaire et ainsi de suite.
Les journalistes qui sont perçus comme défendant un certain ordre établi, une certaine vision du monde-
Ouais
...et qui déplaît à ces personnes. Y a la question aussi des bulles idéologiques quoi. Y a--
les journalistes viennent casser une certaine perception du monde pour ces personnes et ça peut les agacer très fort, comme si le sol s'écroulait sous leurs pieds.
Et donc réaction très agressive, très viscérale, des insultes, du harcèlement, de la misogynie, dans le cas des journalistes femmes.
J'ai entendu beaucoup dans ce que tu disais de, voilà, par exemple ton harceleur JD qui proposait des explications que j'aurais pas de mal à qualifier de complotistes.
Ouais.
Et machin, il était mis en place à la radio parce que truc couche avec machin et truc. Le financement de ton documentaire, ça, on n'en a pas parlé.
Y a eu une thèse qui circulait pendant un moment pour expliquer que-
Ouais
...que le copinage faisait que vous aviez reçu quarante mille euros-
...de fonds publics directement dans votre poche pour travailler sur votre docu.
Oui, c'est ça.
Ce qui n'est pas juste.
Non, c'est pas juste. Mais j'aurais bien aimé, par contre, mais non.
Un autre truc qu'on n'a pas dit, c'est le harceleur en question, quand on l'a sommé de s'expliquer, de : « Mais pourquoi est-ce que tu emmerdes autant Myriam Leroy ?
» Qu'est-ce qu'il avait répondu ?
Il s'était senti pris de haut par moi, qu'il avait l'impression que je le regardais avec dédain et que ça l'a blessé et que comme il était un grand sensible, tout est parti de là.
Ouais, donc y a une question d'ego, une question de-- 'fin voilà, on expliquait au départ que c'est quelqu'un du même milieu que toi, plus ou moins, la presse culturelle belge.
Oui, c'était-- bah disons que c'était un milieu connexe parce que lui, il gagnait pas sa vie en écrivant des articles, mais il faisait des articles de blog, des billets de blog de temps en temps sur des concerts,
sur, voilà, il connaissait certains journalistes.
Beaucoup de journalistes le connaissent, d'ailleurs, beaucoup de journalistes le suivent.
Ouais, cette personne qui,
je crois deviner, aurait beaucoup aimé avoir beaucoup d'attention, avoir beaucoup d'exposition, qu'on fasse très fort attention à lui et que voilà, son petit ton un petit peu particulier, un petit peu singulier sur son blog.
Et puis bah, 'fin, il a jamais vraiment breaké de par son talent. Et une forme de jalousie, je sais pas si on peut dire ça, une forme d'envie qui s'est développée envers toi.
Mais je pense que ces mecs, en général,
ils développent une haine assez tenace parce qu'ils estiment qu'on occupe des places qui leur reviendraient de droit, même s'ils ne font rien pour les occuper, même si on ne donne pas les moyens, même s'ils bossent pas pour.
Mais un des mecs particulièrement coriace que j'ai en embuscade dans ma vie depuis quelques années, donc un autre, lui,
il harcelait une autre journaliste parce qu'elle avait eu des subsides pour faire un podcast alors qu'il estimait que en fait elle aurait pas dû, que ça aurait dû revenir à quelqu'un d'autre, donc à lui, mais il n'avait même pas,
remis de dossier.
'Fin, donc y a quelque chose de : « Cette place me revient, même si je fais rien pour la conquérir, ça ne revient pas à une pauvre, pauvre nana.
» C'est aussi un mec qui disait, une de ses consœurs journalistes musique : « Suceuse de bites de has been » sur Facebook et qui avait des likes et des likes de la profession quoi.
Oui, là où j'aimerais arriver, c'est que, 'fin voilà, tu évoquais il y a un instant le profil de ce journaliste qui disait : « Non, mais non, mais ça devrait être moi » et en fait, il avait même pas soumis de candidature.
Moi, on ne m'a pas traité de suceur de bites, mais je me souviens que
quand j'ai démarré ce podcast et que j'étais très content, ravi d'avoir décroché une interview avec Alexander De Croo alors que j'avais aucune expérience journalistique et que j'en avais parlé à quelqu'un qui était dans mon entourage,
j'avais eu un commentaire du type
: « Mais ça devrait être moi ».
Alors que ce gars bah travaillait lui aussi comme informaticien dans une banque.
Ah, ouf !
C'est pas la même personne. Et ce que je veux dire, c'est que je décèle-- moi, j'hésite pas à parler dans ce genre de cas.
Dans le cas de cette personne-là que j'ai en tête, en ce qui me concerne, t'as un certain narcissisme quoi, beaucoup d'ego, beaucoup d'envie d'être sous les spotlights.
Je voudrais qu'on fasse attention à moi, qu'on me remarque, tout ça.
Fais-le alors.
C'est ça. Et, 'fin encore une fois, c'est une analyse que j'ai envie de proposer, mais je suis pas dans la tête de ces gens hein, je fais un peu la psychologie de comptoir, mais
on avait beaucoup parlé avec Olivier Klein, donc vice-recteur de la faculté de psychologie à l'ULB, de la grande compatibilité entre les profils qui ont envie d'une grande unicité, se sentir unique, se sentir spécial.
Et le complotisme quoi, parce que quand on a une théorie du complot en main, et ben on peut dire : « Mais regardez-moi. Eh, regardez-moi, j'ai la vraie vérité vraie, là.
C'est moi qui sais. Les autres, ils savent pas. Moi, je sais.
Oui, c'est vrai.
Ce qu'on dit, le message qu'on essaie de faire passer dans les médias au sujet de Florence Hainaut, Myriam Leroy, non, ça, c'est pas vrai.
Moi, j'ai la vraie vérité. Et je vais écrire des énormes articles de blog basés sur vraiment pas grand-chose.
Et les rumeurs qui les attrapent au vol, les valorisent parce qu'ils se sentent privilégiés d'y avoir accès, donc de soi-disant faire entendre un autre son de cloche quoi.
Oui. Pardon, je t'ai coupé.
Non, mais voilà, c'est l'analyse que j'ai envie de proposer, la psychologie de comptoir, voilà.
Oui, oui. Bah écoute, je suis accoudée au même comptoir, ouais.
Ça va. Myriam, merci beaucoup pour ces plus de septante minutes passées avec moi. Tu expliquais qu'à partir de maintenant, tu allais être libérée de
ce traînage de boue et cette prison mentale dans laquelle tu restais coincée, pendant toutes ces années.
Est-ce que tu peux nous parler de tes futurs projets, tes prochains projets maintenant que tu es libérée de ça ?
Ouais.
On, parce qu'on disait, tu as fait un documentaire sur le cyberharcèlement, Sale Pute, qui n'est plus dispo, mais qui redeviendra certainement dispo dans les mois qui viennent.
Qui est nominé pour le Magritte du meilleur documentaire, hein, donc-
Mais félicitations.
On en est très fiers.
Mais tu peux l'être. Le roman aussi que tu as publié et qui a été fact-checké par certains de tes harceleurs.
C'est encore une absurdité qu'on n'aura pas le temps d'explorer aujourd'hui. Mais oui, c'est con. C'est-- voilà, c'est toute l'analyse qu'on fournira pour cet épisode.
Est-ce que-- oui, donc tous ces projets-là
Moi, je veux plus, enfin, je veux plus bosser sur le harcèlement.
C'est ça.
Je veux plus bosser. Je veux bien bosser un peu sur la misogynie, hein. Oui, c'est quand même un sujet dont j'ai du mal à contourner.
Mais là, je suis revenue aux choses sérieuses, c'est-à-dire que je suis revenue à mon projet de troisième roman et je kiffe à mort.
C'est-- j'écris un truc sur la Résistance, la Seconde Guerre mondiale, sujet auquel je connaissais pas grand-chose.
L'idée de ce roman, elle est partie du fait que t'avais vu une pierre tombale ou ai-je dit une bêtise ?
Ouais. Je suis tombée, en me promenant avec une amie au cimetière d'Ixelles, que j'avais jamais visité, l'hiver dernier, sur la tombe d'une femme décapitée.
Et c'était marqué « décapitée » sous son nom. Alors évidemment, on était en pleine affaire Samuel Paty, donc cet enseignant français qui avait eu la tête coupée par un dingue qui se réclamait de Daesh.
Donc c'était doublement choquant. Enfin, il y avait quelque chose d'affreux qui résonnait avec ce « décapitée » écrit sur une tombe à moitié effacée.
Et voilà, c'est une sorte d'enquête que je fais, enfin, mais ce sera romancé, sur qui était cette femme et pourquoi est-ce qu'elle a été décapitée.
OK.
Et en fait, plus j'en découvre et plus c'est génial. Cette femme a une vie incroyable. La Belgique sous l'Occupation, je connaissais rien.
Et là, j'ai bouffé à peu près tous les bouquins qui existent sur la question et c'est passionnant. C'est passionnant et ce qui est-- c'est aussi très angoissant parce que, allô, je vais enfoncer une grosse porte ouverte, mais
on n'a pas de mémoire et on est en train de rejouer des choses extrêmement, de manière très troublante, en tout cas dans le langage, ce qui se disait à l'époque-
Oui
...aux portes de la guerre.
Et même l'actualité politique en ce moment qui répète exactement l'actualité politique américaine d'il y a cinq ans.
Donc la mémoire, elle est très très très très très très court terme.
C'est incroyable. Incroyable. Et je suis la première à ne pas m'être intéres--
ne pas m'être intéressée à la Seconde Guerre mondiale, parce que j'ai peut-être-- on m'en a mal parlé, j'en sais rien, mais j'ai toujours trouvé que c'était des souvenirs de petits vieux, en fait, des chromos un peu sépia.
Et je suis passée vachement à côté. Pourtant, mon père est né en 1940. Il a essayé de me parler de la guerre, mais je l'écoutais pas.
Et maintenant, grâce à cette femme décapitée, je m'y intéresse et en fait, on devrait tous s'y intéresser. Oh là là, le nombre de portes ouvertes à défoncer.
Y a une fracture générationnelle assez claire dans le sens où
beaucoup de gens qui ont à peu près mon âge, qui sont de ma génération ou dans ces eaux-là, vont être beaucoup plus ouverts, beaucoup plus tolérants vis-à-vis des blagues sur les nazis, sur les Juifs, sur la Shoah.
Alors que, voilà, les gens qui sont plus âgés vont se sentir beaucoup moins autorisés à rire de ça.
Mais ça dépend qui, hein, parce que je pourrais tenir des heures là-dessus, mais-
Oui pardon, je te lance sur ton obsession là.
Je me rends compte d'être vieille personne et notamment une très vieille dame qui habite juste au-dessus des caves de la Gestapo, avenue Louise, que j'ai visitée.
C'est absolument fou. Alors, je dis pas que ces gens s'en foutent de la guerre, mais : « Oh, c'était déjà assez pénible comme ça.
On va pas commencer à s'appesantir dessus ». En fait, j'ai l'impression que beaucoup de gens qui ont vécu ces années-là ont pas eu envie d'entretenir une mémoire, en particulier en Belgique.
Ils avaient juste envie de profiter de la vie, de fêter-
Tourner la page.
Ouais, c'est ça. Et donc ça, ça manque. Y a quand même beaucoup de choses qui manquent sur la réalité belge, notamment sur la Résistance belge.
Y a peu de choses qui ont été écrites.
Ouais, c'est vrai.
Alors qu'en France, bon, c'est un truc-
Tout à fait
...d'un marronnier, dans les médias. Bon, parce que la Belgique n'a pas la mémoire autoglorifiante de base, mais aussi, bon, parce que les-
C'est un bon tacle
...les résistants ont été récupérés politiquement. Enfin, y a quelque chose qui ne s'est pas-- y a une transformation qui ne s'est pas bien faite au niveau politique, avec la Résistance,
ce qui explique en partie
le fait qu'on ait oublié ce que c'était, et qui c'était les résistants.
Et donc ça me donne un boulevard pour écrire quelque chose qui m'excite à mort là-dessus.
Donc ce sera alors, si j'ai bien compris, docufiction quoi, donc basée sur des faits réels et puis-
Ouais, c'est ça.
...un peu complétée par-
Ouais. Je comble les vides avec de l'invention quoi. 'Fin donc, les pensées du personnage.
C'est ça, ouais, ouais, ouais. Forcément, ouais, les pensées n'étaient pas enregistrées à cette époque-là encore.
OK. Donc c'est un projet de troisième roman. T'as une idée d'une date de sortie, de quand tu penses que tu pourras sortir ça ?
Non, non, je l'ai même pas encore fait lire à qui que ce soit. J'ai peut-être une éditrice, mais c'est même pas sûr, donc-
Oh, tu-- non, non, je peux te le dire que c'est à peu près sûr que tu vas réussir à trouver quelqu'un.
Oui, oui. Oui, oui, mais moi, j'aimerais bien trouver vraiment la bonne personne pour m'accompagner dans ce projet. Donc je suis-- voilà.
Voilà ce que je peux dire. Ça, c'est vraiment mon gros, gros boulot du moment. Et puis voilà, je crois que c'est à peu près tout.
Ouais, je suis aussi en train de bosser sur des scénarios de séries et de films. C'est pas encore assez avancé pour que ce soit pertinent d'en parler.
Mais donc écrire et écrire des comédies aussi, écrire sur d'autres sujets qui me ramènent quand même toujours quelque part à
D'une manière ou d'une autre à la haine des femmes, c'qui est devenu ma spécialité, mais par la bande quoi, pas dans un discours théorique articulé quoi.
C'est plutôt montrer des situations.
Mmh.
Et puis les gens en font c'qu'ils veulent quoi.
Tu ne devrais pas écrire des essais politiques, rajouter des commentaires-
Non, j'crois que je serais vraiment très mauvaise là-dedans. Vraiment à chier, ouais.
OK, ben, j'te crois sur parole. C'est marrant parce qu'à chaque fois que je te demande ça, tu effaces-- mais et tu sais que c'est pour ça que je te pose la question, que c'est à ça que je veux arriver.
Tu effaces ton autre projet de roman-
Ah oui, c'est vrai ! Oui, oui, j'ai un projet de roman. J'ai même reçu une bourse, donc je vais, ne t'inquiète pas, le terminer.
Ouais, tu es obligée.
Sur une femme autiste.
Mmh.
Voilà, qui me ressemble, hein, à certains égards.
Hein, même beaucoup et qui se retrouve, hélas pour elle, enceinte. C'est-- disons que c'est l'histoire d'une femme autiste qui doit se conformer aux attendus de la société-
Mmh, mmh.
...qui sont hyper oppressants, en particulier sur les femmes enceintes. Et... 'Fin, je me suis dit dans-- quelle est la situation qui pourrait être a priori la plus oppressante pour moi et pour les femmes autistes en général.
Mmh.
Et je pense que la grossesse et l'enfantement, ça peut être vraiment un cauchemar pour toute une série de raisons.
Bon, attends, attends, attends Myriam, est-ce que tu viens de faire ton coming out ?
Ah ! Ouais, ouais, j'pense.
J'suis tellement-
Fier et heureux et fier
...'fin, j'suis très, très, très heureux. Mais oui, c'est super, c'est toujours beau un coming out et j'attendais le tien depuis longtemps.
Ah, ok.
J'ai un énorme fichier de notes rempli de choses que j'avais notées dont je m'étais promis de parler avec toi un jour, et ce sera pas aujourd'hui du coup.
Non.
Mais on aura très certainement l'occasion d'en reparler pour un troisième ou quatrième roman.
Quatrième. Ce sera le quatrième.
Je l'avais dit : « Tu es l'unique, tu es la seule personne qui a le droit de revenir dans Septante Minutes Avec une deuxième fois et donc aussi une troisième fois ».
J'essaye de varier un max les intervenants, mais tu es tellement formidable, Myriam !
J'adore cette interview.
Voilà. Est-ce que tu veux rajouter quelque chose pour conclure ? Est-ce qu'on a tout dit sur-
Je pense
...les harceleurs bruxellois et la psychologie de comptoir qu'on peut faire à leur sujet et tes futurs projets ?
Ouais, j'crois qu'on a tout dit. J'crois que je peux juste dire que je suis très contente, que j'ai une gueule de bois monstrueuse, mais que je suis pleine de bonne humeur-
Ah ça, ça n's'est pas entendu
...normalement après votre fou du trou.
Ça ne s'est pas entendu, je ne sais pas remarqué.
J'ai repris un peu de vigueur en cours d'interview, je l'ai senti. J'pense que l'alcool se dissipe. Et puis, encore une fois remercier l'AJP, l'Association des Juristes Professionnels,
sans qui ce rêve n'aurait pas été possible.
Remercier mon avocate, Benjamine Bovy, qui a vraiment été top. Remercier Florence Hainaut parce qu'elle a été à mes côtés pendant tout ce temps.
Et elle, ben son procès n'a-- 'fin voilà, ça n'a pas abouti. Elle avait déposé une plainte en suspectant le même harceleur-
Contre X
...mais ça n'a pas, voilà, ça n'a pas abouti. Donc je pense que c'est aussi une déception pour elle, mais elle a quand même toujours été là, pour me soutenir.
Dire merci à mes amis d'être, bah de m'avoir accompagnée au propre comme au figuré et à mon mec aussi. Et puis te dire merci aussi à toi Guillaume, parce que c'est pas rien quand même de t'avoir dans la team.
Deux interviews de Septante Minutes Avec sur les 10 derniers jours, oui.
Ouais. Et d'avoir accepté de réenregistrer l'interview...
Mais ça va là, là, t'es contente ? T'as pas dit trop de trucs-
Je sais pas, mais moi je me rends pas compte de ce que je dis
...mais c'est parfait. On fera pas écouter aux autres. Ils pourront pas nous dire de pas le publier.
Non, c'est entre nous. C'est entre nous. Bon super, merci Guillaume Hachez.
Merci à toi Myriam et on se retrouve alors dans deux semaines pour une interview d'Axel Cleeremans de l'ULB.
Yeah, c'est chouette.
À très bientôt, au revoir. Et voilà, si vous avez écouté jusqu'au bout, vous savez maintenant que Myriam, comme moi, est autiste.
Ça explique pourquoi on s'entend aussi bien, je pense. Pour celles et ceux qui ne savent pas de quoi il s'agit ou qui ont des vieux stéréotypes en tête, sachez qu'y a plusieurs épisodes où on parle de ça.
Je vous recommande notamment l'épisode avec Julie Dachez ou celui avec Alistair et Elisa Rojas. Je vais pas avoir le temps de tout détailler ici, mais c'est une info qui permet de comprendre énormément de choses sur ce qui est arrivé à Myriam.
Par exemple, voilà, quand elle explique qu'elle parle d'une certaine manière et que ça lui arrive souvent que les gens la trouvent condescendante ou hautaine.
Bah ça, c'est quelque chose qui est hyper récurrent chez les autistes et ça m'est arrivé un paquet de fois aussi. Mais surtout,
la capacité de Myriam à s'extraire des normes sociales et de ce que les femmes doivent être, de comment elles doivent subir le harcèlement, à mes yeux, c'est très clairement aidé par son beau cerveau autiste.
Si vous avez des questions là-dessus, mon adresse email est en description. Je vous encourage à ne pas trop parler de cet aspect-là sur les réseaux sociaux,
précisément parce que c'est un sujet compliqué pour les boomers qui la harcèlent et que ce serait dommage de laisser le mot autiste, encore une fois, être une insulte.
Enfin, n'oubliez pas que je serai à Saint-Gilles le 23 avril prochain pour donner une journée de formation en journalisme où je parlerai plus spécifiquement, voilà, de ce format de podcast interview qui est le mien.
J'ai mis le lien en description. C'est tout pour moi. Je vous souhaite une bonne et heureuse année 2022 et je vous dis à très bientôt.
Salut !
Caramel. Pourquoi tu gémis sur Guillaume Hachez, Caramel ?